हेलो एवरीवन एंड गुड गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल तो
सबसे
पहले मुझे यह बता दीजिए सबको मेरी आवाज
सुनाई दे रही है
एवरीवन
आई एम लाउड एंड क्लियर
ओके गुड इवनिंग सलमान
प्रज्ञा गुड इवनिंग वेरी गुड इवनिंग
हाय अश्विन
हाय आयुष गुड इवनिंग
गुड इवनिंग कुलदीप।
तो थोड़ा सा वेट करते हैं। दो मिनट का
टाइम लेते हैं कि क्लास को स्टार्ट करने
में। तो तब तक मैं लैब स्टार्ट कर लेता
हूं और अपने मशीन को स्टार्ट कर लेते हैं।
तो तब तक जिन स्टूडेंट को ज्वाइन करना है
वह ज्वाइन कर लेंगे। तो नेक्स्ट 2 टू 5
मिनट वेट करते हैं उनका।
हेलो एवरीवन हेलो हेलो
हेलो खुशबान
हाय संगम
हां बता दीजिए अगर किसी को ऐसा लग रहा है
कि वॉल्यूम नहीं आ रही। मेरी तरफ से तो
लाउड एंड क्लियर है और शायद
आपकी तरफ से भी होनी चाहिए।
हाय प्रियंका
अनु प्लीज आप अपने डिवाइस में वॉल्यूम का
कुछ कीजिए क्योंकि जहां तक मुझे पता है
मेरे डिवाइस का कोई इशू नहीं है।
कॉन्फिग
हेलो अनिकेत
आयुष माय डिवाइस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन इज 32GB रैम
एंड i9 प्रोसेसर 1TB हार्ड डिस्क
एंड 12GB ग्राफिक
थैंक यू
आज भी देर ओनली 43 स्टूडेंट्स
वर्चुअल मशीन और वीएमवेयर में क्या क्या
अच्छा है वर्चुअल बॉक्स की बात कर रहे हो
या वीएमवेयर में
नहीं कोई डिफरेंस नहीं है। वर्चुअल बॉक्स
और मीमवेयर दोनों सही है। तो यह डिपेंड
करता है आपके सिस्टम पर कि कौन सा अच्छे
से काम करता है। कौन सा सपोर्टेड सही
तरीके से आपके सिस्टम के लिए कंफर्टेबल है
तो उसी पर डिपेंड करता है। दोनों का काम
वही है वर्चुअल एनवायरमेंट आपको प्रोवाइड
करना इससे ज्यादा कुछ नहीं।
आप कोई भी यूज कर सकते हो वीएमवेयर या
वर्चुअल बॉक्स।
क्योंकि जहां तक मैंने देखा है अपने
एक्सपीरियंस के हिसाब से VMware Windows
के लिए बेस्ट है और वर्चुअल बॉक्स क्या है
कि आपको मैक के लिए ज्यादा अच्छा लगेगा।
मैक के फेस में मैक के टाइम जब मेरे पास
मैक था तो मैंने वर्चुअल बॉक्स काफी
कंफर्टेबली इसे यूज किया है। तो उसमें
मुझे कभी भी ज्यादा बग्स और प्रॉब्लम
प्रॉब्लम फेस करने को नहीं मिलती थी और
वीएमवेयर में फेस करने को मिलती थी। बट
अभी मेरे पास मैक मैक है नहीं तो इसलिए
मैं मैक यूज़ करता नहीं। तो अभी मुझे इसका
आईडिया नहीं है कि सच में अभी चेंज हो गया
या नहीं है।
क्योंकि मैं हर एक ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के साथ
कंफर्टेबल हूं। इवन Windows है, चाहे वह
आपका लinक्स है। Linux में चाहे आपका
पैरेट है, काली है, चाहे आपका रेड रेड हैट
है। मैं हर एक लinक्स मशीन के साथ
कंफर्टेबल हूं।
तो इंटरेस्टिंग के लिए तो काली और पैरेट
दोनों ही बेस्ट है।
डीसीजीएसपी मास्टर कोर्स
ऐसा तो कोई कोर्स नहीं है।
आयुष सच बताऊं तो मैंने अभी तक ब्लैक आर्क
यूज़ नहीं किया है।
हाय ओबिटो ओबिटो ओके सॉरी फॉर
प्रोनाउंसिएशन
ओके आपके वहां गुड आफ्टरनून हुआ है तो ओके
तो वेरी गुड आफ्टरनून
तो जगत गुरु जी आप यूज कीजिए वीएमवेयर
साइबर सिक्योरिटी के लिए टिप्स यही है कि
आप अभी मेरे कोर्स को फॉलो कीजिए। आपको
बहुत कुछ सीखने को मिलेगा। टिप्स ही टिप्स
मिलेंगे आपको। कौन सा टूल्स, कब, कहां,
कैसे और किस अप्रोच में हमें जाना चाहिए।
अभी तो हमने शुरुआत किया है। चलो हमारी
मशीन ऑन हो गई है। और मे बी अभी इट्स टाइम
टू स्टार्ट आवर कोर्स। तो लास्ट क्लास से
रिलेटेड किसी का कोई भी डाउट मुझे नहीं
मिला चैट सेक्शन में। इवन डे वन से ले डे
से तक मैं सारी चैट चेक कर चुका हूं कमेंट
सेक्शन में। तो वहां पर मुझे कोई भी डाउट
नहीं मिला रिलेटेड टू एनी क्लासेस डे वन
टू डे सेवन। तो अभी तक मेरी तरफ से जो
आपका डाउट बोर्ड था उस पे अभी तक निल है।
जो आप लोगों को कोई भी डाउट्स नहीं है। तो
यह गुड भी है और बैड भी है। आई कांट से।
गुड इसलिए या तो मैं इतना अच्छा पढ़ाता
हूं कि आप लोगों को कोई डाउट नहीं है। बैड
इसलिए या मेरा समझ में नहीं आता।
दी आर द टू की फैक्टर्स। तो नो इशू तो अभी
हम कंटिन्यू करेंगे लास्ट क्लास में हमने
जहां से छोड़ा था एन मैप के बारे में और
एक और क्लास होगी हमारी ओनली एनमप के बारे
में जो स्कैनिंग पार्ट है टोटल जो
स्कैनिंग पार्ट चल रहा है आपका एक्टिव
इनेशन गैदरिंग। उसके बाद हम शिफ्ट करेंगे
सेक्शन थ्री एनुमरेशन के ऊपर। तो एक क्लास
और बची हुई है आपकी एन मैप की। तो आज की
क्लास में जो कुछ पढ़ने वाले हैं मैं आपको
बता दूंगा। बेसिकली आज की क्लास में
पढ़ेंगे पोर्ट स्कैनिंग जो आपके थंबनेल्स
पे शो किया हुआ था। दूसरा हम पढ़ने वाले
हैं ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम डिटेक्शन एंड सर्विस
वर्जन डिटेक्शन। थर्ड फायर वाल डिटेक्शन
एंड आईडीएस इवेज बायपास। इंट्रोजन
डिटेक्शन सिस्टम बाईपास। हम ट्राई करेंगे
विद द हेल्प ऑफ एन मैप।
तो अभी हम स्टार्ट करते हैं। जहां से हमने
पिछली क्लास को छोड़ा हुआ था। मैं आपको
थोड़ा सा इंट्रोड्यूस कर देता हूं कि
पिछली क्लास में मैंने आपको एक सिनेरियो
दिया था। सिनेरियो यह था कि आपको एज ए पेन
टेस्टर असाइन किया गया है कंपनी में। आपको
एज ए पेंटेस्टर जॉब रोल प्रोवाइड की गई
है। वहां पर कंपनी ने बोला है कि आपका काम
क्या है कि यह मेरा नेटवर्क है। इस
नेटवर्क में दो सर्वर्स हैं, कुछ पीसेस
हैं। यह जस्ट एग्जांपल है। और आप इस
नेटवर्क से कनेक्टेड हो। बेसिकली सबसे
पॉजिटिव पॉइंट है। तो, आपको क्या करना है
कि मेरे इस नेटवर्क का पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग करना है और बताना है कि कौन-कौन
सी वनेबिरिटीज अभी एग्जिस्ट करती हैं एक
रिपोर्ट में और उनका मिटिगेशन स्टेप क्या
है जो आपकी जॉब का पार्ट है तो यह एक
ब्लैक बॉक्स पेन टेस्टिंग है क्योंकि आपकी
कंपनी ने ना तो कोई आईपी एड्रेस की
इंफॉर्मेशन दी जस्ट आपको उस नेटवर्क के
साथ कनेक्ट कर दिया अभी यह टोटली डिपेंड
करता था आपके माइंडसेट पे आपके स्किल पे
कि आपने क्या सीखा है और कैसे मैं आगे
बढूंगा कौन सी अप्रोच लूंगा तो लास्ट
क्लास में सबसे पहले हमने सीखा था होस्ट
डिस्कवरी विद दी हेल्प ऑफ एन मैप। एन मैप
की हेल्प से हमने होस्ट डिस्कवरी की थी जो
नेक्स्ट स्लाइड कि
हम कनेक्टेड हैं इस इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर के
नेटवर्क से। ओके? तो, हमें आईडिया आया कि
इस नेटवर्क में कौन-कौन से आईपी एड्रेस
एक्टिव हैं। क्योंकि हमने क्या किया था?
होस्ट डिस्कवरी में जो पूरा-पूरा जो सबनेट
था उसको स्कैन किया था। स्कैन करने के बाद
जो एक्टिव होस्ट थे उनकी इंफॉर्मेशन हमारे
पास आ गई थी कि 103 104 159 1818
222 और 225
1 और 160 जिनमें से हमें पता था कि
192.168.160
हैकर्स का आईपी एड्रेस है। अटैकर्स का
आईपी एड्रेस है। जिनमें से गेटवे आईपी
एड्रेस कौन सा हो गया? 192.168.0.1
दिस इज द गेटवे आईपी एड्रेस। ये
इंफॉर्मेशन हमारे पास है। लेकिन होस्ट
डिस्कवरी अटैक से टेक्निक अटैक से या
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग स्टेप से हमने यह तो
पता कर लिया कि इस पूरे नेटवर्क पर
कौन-कौन से होस्ट एक्टिव हैं। लेकिन अभी
तक हमारे पास यह कोई भी इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं
है कि इस मशीन का आईपी एड्रेस इनमें से
कौन सा है या इस मशीन का कौन सा आईपी
एड्रेस है। इन IP एड्रेस में से इन मशीन
पर कौन सा IPपी एड्रेस एग्जिस्ट करता है।
ये इंफॉर्मेशन मेरे पास नहीं है कि जब फॉर
एग्जांपल ये एक सर्वर है तो इस सर्वर का
आईपी एड्रेस इनमें से कौन सा है या इस
सर्वर का आईपी एड्रेस इनमें से कौन सा है
या इस मशीन का आईपी एड्रेस इनमें से कौन
सा है या जो ये तीन और मशीन बच गई आपके जो
पीसीज हैं पर्सनल कंप्यूटर हैं या लैपटॉप
हैं उनका आईपी एड्रेस कौन सा है यह
इंफॉर्मेशन हमारे पास अभी तक नहीं है।
जब हमें सॉरी अब हमें ये इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए
तो इस इंफॉर्मेशन के लिए हम क्या करेंगे?
फर्दर स्टेप फॉलो करेंगे जो कौन सा आता है
आपका? पोर्ट स्कैनिंग। फर्दर स्टेप फॉलो
क्या करेंगे हम? पोर्ट स्कैनिंग।
कोई नहीं आयुष आप पहली बार आए हो तो कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है। तो आप पिछले सेशन को कवर
कर लीजिए। आपको जैसे-जैसे टाइम मिलेगा बीच
में क्लासेस का गैप रहेगा और जितने भी
सेशन लाइव आते हैं उनको मिस मत करना।
अदरवाइज आपको कुछ भी समझ में नहीं आएगा।
इट्स माय गारंटी। ओके? तो अभी हम स्टार्ट
करते हैं स्पोर्ट स्कैनिंग से।
अभी मैं आपको बताता हूं पोर्ट स्कैनिंग
क्यों जरूरत है? जरूरी है क्योंकि देखिए
होस्ट डिस्कवरी से पता चल गया लाइव होस्ट
लेकिन अब पोर्ट ही है जिनकी हेल्प से या
जो सर्विसेज हैं या ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है
इन्हीं की हेल्प से मैं पता कर सकता हूं
कि ओके इस नेटवर्क में यह ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
ऑपरेट कर रहा है और इसका IP एड्रेस यह है।
क्योंकि किसी भी मशीन के ऊपर जो भी
पोर्ट्स ओपन होंगे उसके बेस पर हम आईडिया
लगा सकते हैं। एक नेटवर्क मैप कर सकते
हैं। एक रफ आईडिया या एक रफ हमारे पास मैप
होगा नेटवर्क का कि ओके इस IP एड्रेस ये
अगर फॉर एग्जांपल 104 IPपी एड्रेस है तो
हो सकता है कि ओके यह Linux का IPपी
एड्रेस है। इस पे ये सर्विस रन करनी है तो
मतलब यह Linux की सर्विज है। तो यह एक
Linux का IPपी एड्रेस है। तो इससे हमें एक
रफ आईडिया मिलेगा नेटवर्क का कि ओके कि यह
एक सर्वर है। तो यह कौन सा सर्वर है और
इसका IPपी एड्रेस कौन सा है? क्योंकि देखो
आई सर्विज और ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स के बेस पर
ही हम पता कर सकते हैं कि इनमें कौन सी
मशीन क्या है। ओके तो अभी हम बात करते हैं
पोर्ट स्कैनिंग की। दिस इज द मोस्टेंट फेस
ऑफ पेन टेस्टिंग क्योंकि
ओनली होस्ट डिस्कवरी के बेस पर हम नहीं
बता सकते कि कौन सी मशीन कौन से कौन सी
मशीन कौन सी है। ओके नाउ अभी हम स्टार्ट
करते हैं। तो मे बी लास्ट क्लास सबको
क्लियर है। डे से एवरीवन
चलो एक और चीज बता देता हूं आप लोगों को
मैं सबसेेंट चीज कि आप लोगों को सर नोट्स
से रिलेटेड क्वरी रहती है तो नोट्स मेरे
हमेशा ये रहा मेरा Lindin पेज है फॉर
एग्जांपल ये रहा ये ये मेरी Lindin आईडी
है सेम सैम नाम से ओके तो बहुत सारे लोगों
की रिक्वेस्ट आई है मैंने एक्सेप्ट भी की
है तो यहां पर मैं हमेशा
आर्टिकल्स में विद नोट्स आपको क्या करता
हूं प्रोवाइड करता हूं फॉर एग्जांपल अगर
आप देखोगे तो यहां पर पोस्ट एंड एक्टिविटी
में जाता हूं। तो मेरी यह थी जैसे कि
सिक्स मंथ हमारा डीसीएसपी जो कोर्स है
उसकी भी मैंने आपको इंफॉर्मेशन दी हुई है।
और इवन जो डे सिक्स और सेवन है मैंने
थोड़ा सा ब्रीफ दिया है। उसमें क्या
पढ़ाया गया है और साथ की साथ मैंने भी ये
सारे के सारे जो पीपीटी नोट्स हैं उनको
पीएजी फाइल में फोटो के फ्रेम में मैंने
अपलोड किया हुआ है। तो आप यहां से सारे
नोट्स देख सकते हो। तो इवन आप चाहो तो मे
बी मैंने देखा नहीं है कि आप डाउनलोड कर
पाओगे नहीं कर पाओगे लेकिन आप यहां से
सारे के सारे नोट्स पढ़ सकते हो। तो यह
मेरी lindin प्रोफाइल्स है। मैं सर को
बोला है कि सर इस पोस्ट को रीपस्ट कर
देंगे। सर थोड़े से बिजी हैं इसलिए
रीपोस्ट नहीं कर पाए डेफोनिक्स वाले पेज
पर तो वहां पर भी आपको ये नोट्स अवेलेबल
मिल जाएंगे। ओके? तो मे बी आपके नोट्स से
रिलेटेड आपके डाउट क्लियर हो गए। यहां पर
अभी तक डे से तक जितने भी नोट्स हैं सारे
नोट्स प्रोवाइड किए गए हैं। चलो अभी बात
करते हैं। तो दे आर टोटल 51 स्टूडेंट्स।
तो
51 स्टूडेंट्स में से अभी
100 में से 51 मतलब 6000 की स्ट्रेंथ है
हमारे YouTube चैनल पर मतलब उस पे हमारे
क्या बोलते हैं WhatsApp चैनल पे और
जिनमें से ओनली 51 आर लाइव।
कोई नहीं चलो
सबसे पहले हम पोर्ट स्कैनिंग के बारे में
पढ़ते हैं। पोर्ट स्कैनिंग सबको स्क्रीन
दिखाई दे रही है? सबको क्लियर दिखाई दे
रहा है स्क्रीन? एवरीवन
सबको विज़िबल है?
कोई ऐसा तो नहीं है जिसको स्क्रीन दिखाई
नहीं दे रही हो या फोंट साइज छोटा दिखाई
दे रहा हो।
ओके
चलो अभी हम बात करते हैं। पहले मैं रूट
यूजर बन जाता हूं।
ओके सोो सबको लinक्स आता है ना अभी या कोई
ऐसा जिसको लinक्स नहीं आता यहां पर
सभी को लinक्स आता है
अखिलेश राव पीडीएफ अपलोड नहीं होती
Instagram पर उस पे सॉरी हमारे
Lindin पर थोड़ी सी डिसएडवांटेज या तो
लिंक अप आपको Google ड्राइव लिंक देना
होगा या उस पे आपको पीएजी या जेपीजी इमेज
में भेजना होगा।
ओके देखिए अभी हम बात करते हैं
पोर्ट डिस्कवरी की। तो सबसे पहले एक बार
मैं फिर से आपके सामने शो कर देता हूं कि
कौन-कौन से आईपी एड्रेस मेरी मशीन में
एक्टिव हैं। उसके लिए मुझे क्या करना
पड़ेगा? सबसे पहले मैं क्या करता हूं? एन
मैप बताइए क्या करना होगा मुझे? एन मैप
हफन
बताइए। बताइए
सिल स्कैन ओके टीसीp सिल स्कैन उसके बाद
मैं यूज़ करने वाला हूं hfन टी फोर उसके
बाद IP एड्रेस मैं फुल गेटवे पास कर रहा
हूं 192.168042
[संगीत]
ओके
चलो
नाउ दीज़ आर द मशीनंस। अभी हम बात करते हैं
ये रही।
एंड यह अपना 225 और 160 ओके 160 हमारी
अटैकर्स की मशीन है। अभी मैं बात करता हूं
अपने पोर्ट स्कैनिंग की। जब भी हम क्या
करते हैं एन मैप हफन और डायरेक्टली फॉर
एग्जांपल अभी मेरा टारगेट है 192.18.0
यह मेरा टारगेट है एक IPपी एड्रेस। और
डायरेक्टली जैसे ही मैं यह एंटर करूंगा तो
इसको हम बोलते हैं इस टेक्निक को। तो अगर
मैं डायरेक्टली एनम मैप स्पेस टारगेट आईपी
एड्रेस मेंशन करता हूं तो इस टेक्निक को
हम बोलते हैं डिफॉल्ट एन मैप पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग। डिफॉल्ट एन मैप पोर्ट स्कैन
बोलते हैं इसको। इसका मतलब क्या है? फॉर
एग्जांपल अगर आप एज ए प्रिविलेज यूजर
प्रिविलेज्ड यूजर का मतलब क्या है? कि आप
रूट यूजर अगर एन मैप को एज ए प्रिविलेज्ड
यूजर यूज़ कर रहे हो लाइक दैट जैसे मैं यूज़
कर रहा हूं। तो यहां पर क्या करता है
आपका? जो एनमप है वह जितने भी पोर्ट्स हैं
उन सबको क्या भेजता है? टीसीपी सिन पैकेट
भेजता है। टीसीपी सिन पैकेट भेजता है।
बेसिकली डिफॉल्ट पोर्ट स्कैनिंग जो होती
है, डिफॉल्ट पोर्ट स्कैनिंग होती है,
उसमें क्या होता है कि सबसे पहले एनमप
होस्ट डिस्कवरी परफॉर्म करता है
ऑटोमेटिकली। उसके बाद जितने भी पोर्ट्स
हैं, जो भी पोर्ट रेंज आप स्पेसिफाई करते
हो किसके अंदर? अपने एनमप के अंदर। चाहे
एक पोर्ट हो या एक पोर्ट रेंज मेंशन करते
हो उन सब हर एक पर्टिकुलर पोर्ट पे क्या
करता है टीसीपी सिन पैकेट भेजता है और जब
उसका रिस्पांस आता है हर एक पोर्ट से अगर
सन एसी के रिस्पांस आता है तो आपको शो
करके दिखाता है कि ओके यह पोर्ट ओपन है
अगर रिस्पांस में आरएसटी पैकेट मिलता है
तो पोर्ट इज क्लोज पोर्ट इज क्लोज ओके
तो यह कहानी है। तो यह क्या है आपका?
डिफॉल्ट एन मैप पोर्ट स्कैनिंग। डिफॉल्ट
एन मैप पोर्ट स्कैनिंग। अभी मैंने आपको
बोला कि यह क्या करता है कि जितने भी आई
पोर्ट्स हैं उनको भेजता है टीसीp सिन
पैकेट। अभी यहां पर मैंने कोई भी पोर्ट
मेंशन नहीं किया। ना तो कोई सिंगल पोर्ट
मेंशन किया ना ही मैंने यहां पर कोई भी
पोर्ट पोर्ट रेंज मेंशन की। मतलब क्या है
कि अगर हम एन मैप के अंदर
कोई भी पोर्ट स्पेसिफाई नहीं करते। कोई भी
पोर्ट नंबर अगर स्पेसिफाई नहीं करते तो
डिफॉल्ट क्या करता है आपका? एन मैप स्कैन
करता है मोस्ट कॉमनली 1000 पोर्ट्स। बाय
डिफॉल्ट इट विल स्कैन मोस्ट कॉमनली यूज्ड
1000 पोस्ट। ठीक है? 1000 पोर्ट्स को
स्कैन करता है। तो अभी यह क्या करेगा?
यहां पर मैंने यहां पर कोई भी कोट में
पोर्ट मेंशन नहीं किया। तो, यह क्या
करेगा? बाय डिफॉल्ट जो कॉमन पोर्ट्स हैं
जो एन मैप के स्क्रिप्ट में डिफाइन किए गए
जो एन मैप के टूल में डिफाइन किए गए हैं
जो मोस्ट कॉमन पोर्ट्स है उनको स्कैन
करेगा तो जैसे मैं हिट एंटर किया तो यह
क्या करना स्टार्ट कर दिया डिफॉल्ट पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग कर दी इसने अभी देखिए
तो यह आपके सामने शो कर रहा है कि 980
पोर्ट्स आर क्लोज्ड टीसीपी पोर्ट्स आर
क्लोज्ड एंड बाकी जो बचे हुए पोर्ट्स हैं
यह आपके सामने स्टेट के साथ है जैसे कि
21 22 80 135 139 445 3306 33389 48 48
7676 800980808181
तो दीज़ आर द लिस्ट ऑफ़ पोर्ट्स दैट आर
ओपन्स ऑन दिस मशीन ओके साथ में देखिए बस
ओनली क्या इनेशन दे रहा है आपके पोर्ट की
इनेशन अगर मैं चेक करूं इसको एन मैप अभी
मैं चेक करता हूं 104 के लिए फॉर एग्जांपल
104 के लिए अभी देखिए देखिए
इट विल टेक टाइम एक और चीज याद रखना यहां
पर सबसे देखो यहां पर एक और चीज याद रखना
यहां पर अभी दे आर थ्री पोर्ट्स आर ओपन
902 912 और 5357
और दिस इज़ अ मैक एड्रेस एंड होस्ट इज़ अप
एंड होस्ट के बारे में कोई इनेशन नहीं दी
आर द थ्री सर्विसेज आर रनिंग एंड 997
फिल्टर टीसीबी पोर्ट्स नो रिस्पांस। ओके?
तो आपको हमेशा एक चीज का ध्यान रखना है।
खासकर कि जब आप विंडो मशीन से डील करोगे
या Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम से डील करोगे
या ऐसे होस्ट से डील करोगे जिसके ऊपर
फिल्टर्ड हैं। जिसके ऊपर फिल्टर अप्लाई
किए गए हैं पोर्ट को ब्लॉक करने के लिए या
पोर्ट के रिस्पांस को ब्लॉक करने के लिए।
मतलब आपके जो होस्ट डिस्कवरी प्रोब
रिक्वेस्ट होती हैं जो होस्ट डिस्क प्रोब
रिक्वेस्ट है उनको ब्लॉक करने के लिए अगर
कोई भी फ़्टर लगाया गया है तो उस केस में
आपको यूज़ करना है
हफन पी एन ऑप्शन हफन पीएन ऑप्शन मतलब मेरे
कहने का मतलब क्या है n मैप
हफन पी और एन हफन पीn उसके बाद 1921680
डॉट फॉर एग्जांपल अभी मैं बात कर रहा हूं
वन
8 वन की बात कर रहा हूं मैं। 1881 की बात
कर रहा हूं। यह रहा। अभी इस केस में क्या
है कि एनएफ को हमने इंस्ट्रक्शन दिया कि
आपको पोर्ट स्कैनिंग करनी है। लेकिन होस्ट
डिस्कवरी को स्कैन क्या करना है? स्किप
करना है कि इसका मतलब क्या है? पीएन का
मतलब क्या है? स्किप द होस्ट डिस्कवरी
स्टेप। ओनली डू द पोर्ट स्कैनिंग। ओनली डू
द पोर्ट स्कैनिंग। आपको ओनली क्या करना
है? पोर्ट स्कैन करना है।
ओके
एवरीवन गॉट क्लियर यहां तक सबको समझ में आ
रहा है मैंने आपको क्या बताया कि आपको अगर
आप किसी भी विंडो मशीन के साथ स्कैनिंग
परफॉर्म कर रहे हो या कोई ऐसा होस्ट है
जिसके ऊपर फिल्टर अप्लाई किए गए हैं जो
आपके जो होस्ट डिस्कवरी प्रोब्स हैं जो
रिक्वेस्ट है उनको ब्लॉक कर रहा है तो उस
केस में आपको क्या करना है एन मैप हफन पीए
हफन पीए ऑप्शन को यूज करना है ताकि जो
आपका होस्ट डिस्कवरी वाली जो पिंग स्कैन
है, पिंग स्कैन है, उसको आप क्या करोगे?
स्किप करके डायरेक्टली पोर्ट स्कैनिंग
करोगे। ठीक है? जिससे भी आपको पता चल
जाएगा कि एक तो कौन-कौन से पोर्ट्स उसके
ऊपर रनिंग कंडीशन में है। दूसरा उससे आपको
पता चल जाएगा कि होस्ट अप है या डाउन है।
ओके?
नाउ। उसके बाद अगर मैं बात करता हूं मैंने
आपको क्या बताया था स्टार्टिंग में अगर आप
एक प्रिविलेज्ड यूजर हैं। आप एक
प्रिविलेज्ड यूजर हैं। एक रूट यूजर है। जब
आप एनमप को परफॉर्म कर रहे हो तो यह क्या
करता है? आपका टीसीp सिम पैकेट भेजता है।
अगर आप नॉन प्रिविलेज्ड यूजर हो मतलब रूट
यूजर नहीं हो। आप एक नॉर्मल यूज़र्स हो।
अगर एज ए नॉर्मल यूजर आप डायरेक्टली इस
कमांड को रन करने की कोशिश करते हो। एन
मैप अभी मैं क्या करता हूं? एग्जिट करता
हूं। इससे बाहर आ जाता हूं। नॉन प्रीलिड
यूजर हूं मैं अभी। तो मैं एन मैप परफॉर्म
करता हूं। उसके बाद 192.168.0
डॉट अभी मैं बात करता हूं 159 की और हिट
एंटर कर दिया मैंने। अभी मैंने क्या किया?
हिट एंटर। और यहां पर आपको देखने को क्या
मिल रहा है? दिस इज़ अननोन पोर्ट। दिस इज़
iPhone सिंक व्हाटएवर। एंड दिस इज़ अ क्लोज
पोर्ट। देयर आर 998 क्लोज पोर्ट्स। तो इस
केस में क्या किया कि जो आपका एनमप है
एनमप क्या करता है पूरा कंप्लीट थ्री वे
हैंडशक फॉलो करता है कंप्लीट थ्री वे
हैंडशक फॉलो करता है जो पैकेट भेजता है
पहले सीन पैकेट भेजता है रिस्पांस में सीन
एसी के मिलता है उसके बाद उसका रिप्लाई
करता है एकनॉलेजमेंट
मतलब एक पूरा कनेक्शन इस्टैब्लिश करता है
थ्री वे देन उसके बाद आपके सामने रिजल्ट
शो करता है कि ओके यह यह पोर्ट ओपन है यह
पोर्ट क्लोज है ओके देन ओनली अभी आप
बोलोगे सर ये अप्रोच तो काफी कंफर्टेबल
अप्रोच है और एक अच्छी अप्रोच है बट
ऑब्वियसली इट इज अ ग्रेट अप्रोच
बट वी वांट कंप्रहेंसिव इंफॉर्मेशन व्हाइल
डूइंग पोर्ट स्कैनिंग मतलब मेरे कहने का
मतलब है कि जब आप पोर्ट स्कैन करते हो तो
आप क्या चाहते हो किसी भी पोर्ट के बारे
में एक कंप्रहेंसिव रिपोर्ट चाहिए एक
कंप्रहेंसिव इंफॉर्मेशन
अगर आपको किसी भी पोर्ट के बारे में
कंप्रहेंसिव इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए तो उस केस
में आपको यूज़ करना होगा पोर्ट नंबर। आपको
पोर्ट स्पेसिफाई करने होंगे जिस पोर्ट के
बारे में आपको कंप्रहेंसिव इनेशन चाहिए या
एक पोर्ट की रेंज स्पेसिफाई करनी होगी या
आपको सारे के सारे पोर्ट ऑल 65535
जो पोर्ट्स हैं उनको मेंशन करना होगा कि
ओके मुझे इन सभी पोर्ट्स पे
कंप्प्रिहेंसिव इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए। तो ये
सारे आपको खुद से मेंशन करने होंगे। यह
कैसे मेंशन करेंगे वह भी मैं आपको
बताऊंगा। अभी मैं स्क्रीन को क्लियर कर
लेता हूं। तो मैंने अभी कुछ स्पोर्ट्स को
चेक कर लिया। अभी मैं एक बार मैं टारगेट
मशीन का आईपी एड्रेस देख लेता हूं। सो दैट
कि
ओके।
ओके नाउ
अभी एन मैप में एक फास्ट स्कैन फास्ट
प्रोफाइल स्कैन फास्ट स्कैनिंग प्रोफाइल
ऑप्शन होता है। कौन सा होता है आपके सामने
मैं बता देता हूं। वेट ओके फ़ास्ट
स्कैनिंग प्रोफाइल ऑप्शन
प्रोफाइल ऑप्शन। अभी यह क्या करता है? अभी
इसके अंदर जब हम फास्ट स्कैनिंग प्रोफाइल
ऑप्शन को यूज करते हैं एन मैप के अंदर तो
यह क्या करता है? जो बाय डिफॉल्ट जो मोस्ट
कॉमन 1000 पोर्ट्स है उसमें 1000
स्पोर्ट्स के बजाय मोस्ट कॉमन जो 100
पोर्ट्स हैं उनको स्कैन करता है और आपके
सामने आउटपुट को शो करता है। इससे क्या
होता है? आपकी टाइम सेविंग होती है। इससे
क्या होता है? आपकी टाइम सेविंग होती है।
ओके? तो अभी मैं फिर से एक बार रूट यूजर
बन जाता हूं और आपके सामने परफॉर्म करके
दिखाता हूं। ये रहा कैसे परफॉर्म करते
हैं? एन मैप हफन पीए स्किप द होस्ट
डिस्कवरी देन उसके बाद हफन एफ हफन कैपिटल
एफ इसका मतलब है फास्ट स्कैनिंग भी बोल
सकते हैं आप नहीं सुना होगा या फास्ट
प्रोफाइल स्कैन भी बोल सकते हैं देन उसके
बाद आपका टारगेट आईपी एड 1921 168
0.181
ओके देखिए यह मोस्ट कॉमनली 100 पोर्ट्स
देखिए देयर आर 92 फिल्टर्ड टीसीपी पोर्ट्स
एंड दीज़ आर द कौन से टीसीपी पोर्ट दिस 21
2280 445 एंड 631 30003068080
दिस इज़ द मैक एड्रेस ओके तो ये इंफॉर्मेशन
आपके सामने देखने को मिल रही है।
वेट वेट गाइज़ एक मिनट मेरी जो मशीन है
थोड़ी सी प्रॉब्लमेटिक कर रही है तो कोई
इशू नहीं है। तो यह आपको पता चल गया अगर
लेकिन जब भी आप फास्ट स्कैनिंग प्रोफाइल
का चूज़ करते हो तो वहां पर एक चीज ध्यान
में रखनी है कि आपको यहां पर कोई भी पोर्ट
मेंशन नहीं करना है। आपको यहां पर कोई भी
पोर्ट या कोई भी पोर्ट रेंज जो रेंज ऑफ़
पोर्ट है वह आपको मेंशन नहीं करनी है।
जिसको आप अपनी इच्छा से स्कैन करना चाहते
हो। इस केस में क्या है? यह आपका टोटल
इनसेंसिबल मतलब कोई भी सेंस क्रिएट नहीं
करता। तब फास्ट स्कैनिंग प्रोफाइल यूज़
करने कोई मतलब नहीं क्योंकि वो तब वो काम
करता ही नहीं। बेसिकली यह आपको अपने दिमाग
में ध्यान ध्यान रखनी है बात कि अगर आप यह
वाली कमांड यूज़ करना चाहते हो कि एन मैप
हफन पीएन हफन एफ मतलब आप फास्ट स्कैन करना
चाहते हो तो यहां पर आप खुद से कोई भी
पोर्ट मेंशन नहीं कर सकते। ओके? अदरवाइज़
यह यूज़लेस है आपके लिए। तो यह चीज आपको
ध्यान में रखनी है। अभी आपको मैं आपको
सिखाता हूं कि फॉर एग्जांपल यह मेरा
टारगेट है। यह टारगेट पे मुझे अभी मैं एक
बार दिखा देता हूं। फास्ट स्कैन परफॉर्म
किया और इसके लिए मैं अभी एक बार नॉर्मल
स्कैनिंग परफॉर्म करता हूं। और एक बार
देखते हैं कौन-कौन सी पोर्ट्स ओपन है। तो
मैं फर्दर क्या कर सकता हूं? अकॉर्डिंग टू
पोर्ट भी मैं क्या कर सकता हूं? स्कैनिंग
कर सकता हूं। पोर्ट डिफाइन करके। मैं रेंज
भी डिफाइन कर सकता हूं या पोर्ट नंबर भी
डिफाइन कर सकता हूं। कैसे कर सकते हैं?
मैं आपको दिखाता हूं।
फास्ट स्कैन में कुछ भी डिसएडवांटेज नहीं
है। जब भी मैं जब भी हम क्या करते हैं जब
इनिशियल में टारगेट के साथ इंगेज करते हैं
तो हम सबसे पहले अपना टाइम बचाने के लिए
फास्ट स्कैन ही परफॉर्म करते हैं। फास्ट
स्कैन ही परफॉर्म करते हैं। सो दैट कि
उससे हमें आईडिया लग जाएगा कि ओके कौन-कौन
से पोर्ट्स उसके ऊपर ओपन है। मोस्ट कॉमन
100 पोर्ट्स ऊपर से यह भी पता चल जाए कि
आपका होस्ट आपका लाइव है या डेड है। ओके।
अह
NMAP hfन PN देन उसके बाद मैं यूज़ करता
हूं
डायरेक्टली टारगेट IP 192.168.0.
222 ओके यह देखिए।
अभी मैं फॉर एग्जांपल एक पर्टिकुलर IPपी
एड्रेस कोई स्कैन करना चाहता हूं। फॉर
एग्जांपल मैं 135 नहीं 445 135 और 3389
इन्हीं के बेस पर स्कैनिंग परफॉर्म करना
चाहता हूं। मैं कैसे कर सकता हूं? देखिए
एन मैप स्किप द आपका होस्ट डिस्कवरी स्टेप
देन हफन पी उसके बाद आपको मेंशन करना है
139 पोर्ट नंबर कॉमा 445 पोर्ट नंबर देन
उसके बाद 3389
और उसके बाद टारगेट IPपी एड्रेस
192.168.22
हिट एंटर
तो इसने आपके सामने क्या है ओनली तीन
पोर्ट्स की इनेशन बता ये तीनों तीनों
पोर्ट्स क्या आपके ओपन पोर्ट्स हैं। तो आप
स्पेसिफिक पोर्ट्स के बारे में भी
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग कर सकते हो। पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग कर सकते हो इन द एन मैप। अगर
मुझे यहां पर कोई रेंज डिफाइन करनी है तो
मैं कैसे करूंगा? एन मैप हफन पी एन एंड
हफन पी। उसके बाद मैं फॉर एग्जांपल मैं
स्कैन करना चाहता हूं। फर्स्ट वन से लेके
1000 तक ओनली फर्स्ट 1000 पोर्ट को स्कैन
करना चाहता हूं। तो देन 192.168.0
222 ये रहा।
ये आपके फर्स्ट 1000 पोर्ट्स को इसने क्या
किया? स्कैन करके आपके सामने आउटपुट शो कर
दिया। अगर मैं क्या चाहता हूं कि जितने भी
535 जो पोर्ट्स हैं सबको स्कैन करना चाहता
हूं। मतलब कंप्लीट
तो मैं वो भी कर सकता हूं। उसके लिए मैं
क्या करूंगा? एन मैप हफन पी एन हफन मैं
क्या करना चाहता हूं? पी उसके बाद डैश
सिंपली डैश उसके बाद 192.168.0.22
यह रहा हिट एंटर। नाउ
यह आपकी कंप्लीट यह टाइम जरूर लेगा। इट
विल टेक टाइम क्योंकि आप पूरे 65535
पोर्ट्स को स्कैन कर रहे हो जिसमें आपको
टाइम लेगा ही लेगा। बट इसने जल्दी से
स्कैन कर दिया। देखिए यहां पर यह सारे के
सारे पोर्ट्स को इसने स्कैन कर दिया। यहां
पर क्या है? 65499
पोर्ट्स आर क्लोज्ड। जिनमें से बाकी बचे
हुए पोर्ट्स के स्टेटस आपके सामने हैं। तो
अभी यह पहले से वनेबल मशीन है। तो इतने
सारे पोर्ट्स आपको ओपन देखने को मिलेंगे।
अगर मैं अपने रियल मशीन पे टेस्ट करूंगा
तो इट विल टेक टाइम। लॉट ऑफ़ टाइम। यह बहुत
ज्यादा टाइम लेगा लेकिन आपके सामने आउटपुट
जरूर शो करेगा। तो यह तरीका था आपके सामने
पोर्ट स्कैनिंग का और भी बहुत सारे तरीके
हैं। फॉर एग्जांपल अभी मैं आपको हम वहा से
आप खुद से कैप्चर करके देख लोगे। शायद
मुझे वx वाएसआर के थ्रू आपको कुछ भी शो
करके दिखाने की जरूरत नहीं हो। ओके? वएसआर
के थ्रू तो आप खुद से कर लोगे ना कैप्चर
ट्रैफिक।
अभी एक और चीज आपको मैं बता देता हूं।
इंपॉर्टेंट पॉइंट कि कई बार आपके सामने
ऐसे केसेस भी होंगे जहां पर आपको कुछ भी
रिस्पांस नहीं मिलेगा क्योंकि देखो आपको
नहीं पता टूल को पता है टूल के पास कोई भी
रिस्पांस नहीं आएगा जिसमें आप समझोगे क्या
है पोर्ट इज क्लोज्ड आप क्या समझोगे फॉर
एग्जांपल आपने टीसीपी सिन पैकेट भेजा सीन
पैकेट के बदले में उन्हें ना तो एसी के
पैकेट भेजा एसी के सीन पैकेट भेजा ना ही
आरएसटी पैकेट भेजा मतलब कुछ रिप्लाई किया
ही नहीं आपके होस्ट ने तो उस केस में आप
क्या समझोगे कि ओके यहां पर पोर्ट क्लोज
है इसलिए वहां पर कोई भी रिप्लाई नहीं आ
रहा। लेकिन यहां पर मतलब सीधा सा मतलब
क्या है कि जो आपका होस्ट है उसके ऊपर
फायर वाल कॉन्फ़िगर है या कोई फिल्टर
कॉन्फ़िगर है जो आपको क्या कर रहा है? आपके
इनकमिंग और आउटगोइंग ट्रैफिक को मॉनिटर
करके आपको इवन रिस्पांस करने से भी क्या
कर रहा है? ब्लॉक कर रहा है। मतलब आपके जो
स्कैनिंग रिस्पांस है उसको क्या कर रहा
है? ब्लॉक कर रहा है। तो, यह चीज आपको
ध्यान में रखनी है कि अगर आपको
कोई भी रिस्पांस नहीं मिलता आपके प्रोब
रिक्वेस्ट का। तो इसका मतलब यह नहीं है कि
वहां पर पोर्ट क्लोज है। इसका मतलब यह भी
हो सकता है कि वहां पर कोई भी फायर वाल
क्फ़िगर है। 99% चांसेस वहां पर कि आपके
फायर वाल कॉन्फ़िगर है और या कोई फिल्टर
मैकेनिज्म का यूज़ किया गया है जो आपको
रिस्पांस करने से भी रोक रहा है। अदरवाइज
क्या है? बाय डिफ़ॉल्ट रिस्पांस करता ही
है। आपका आपका जो भी मशीन से चाहे आपका
खुद का पीसी हो चाहे आपका सर्वर हो। ओके।
एवरीवन गॉट क्लियर टिल नाउ।
लेकिन पोर्ट स्कैनिंग में सबसे मोस्ट
प्रेफरेबल जो आपके जो एक कमांड होती है जो
सभी बताते हैं कि दिस इज़ द मोस्ट प्रेफर्ड
कमांड और आपको यह यूज़ करनी चाहिए और शेप
भी है या स्टिलथर है जिसको बोलते हैं वो
होती है आपकी एनमप हफन पीए स्किप द होस्ट
डिस्कवरी हफन एस एस यह क्या आपको टीसीपी
सीन पैकेट का यूज़ करना है स्कैनिंग के
दौरान और हफन फॉर एग्जांपलस्ट स्कैन मैं
यूज़ करने वाला हूं और 192 2.1
फॉर एग्जांपल 168.0
81 को लेते हैं अब की बार 181 हिट एंटर
देखिए
इसका मतलब क्या है कि आपके दिमाग में सवाल
तो जरूर आएगा कि सर इसको मोस्ट स्टिल थियर
क्यों बोलते हैं? मोस्ट सेफ वे क्यों
बोलते हैं? कि जब हम क्या करते हैं कि इस
कमांड को हर कोई बताता है कि यह प्रेफर्ड
कमांड आपको यह कमांड यूज़ करनी चाहिए।
बाकी
ऑप्शंस के बजाय लेकिन इसको मोस्ट प्रेफर्ड
ऑप्शन क्यों माना गया जिसको स्टिल थियरल
सुना होगा आपने मोस्ट सेफ या स्टिल थियर
ऑप्शन क्यों माना गया इसके दो कारण है
सबसे पहला कारण तो क्या है कि जो भी आपका
पोर्ट है जो भी आपका पोर्ट है यह उस पोर्ट
को वही पैकेट भेजता है जो आपका पोर्ट
एक्सपेक्ट कर रहा है आपका पोर्ट क्या
एक्सपेक्ट कर रहा है टीसीपी के टाइम पे
सिम पैकेट टीसीp सिम पैकेट और यह टीसीपी
सिम पैकेट भेज रहा है मतलब
यह कोई भी अनकॉमन या अनयूजुअल बिहेवियर
नहीं है। ठीक है? कि ऐसा नहीं है कि आप
टीसीपी सिन पैकेट भेज रहे हो कि यह एक
अनकॉमन या अनयुअल बिहेवियर है। नहीं
नेटवर्क के अंदर सिन पैकेट का जाना किसी
भी पोर्ट के ऊपर एक आम बात है। मतलब यह
कोई भी सिक्योरिटी के ऊपर अलार्म रेज नहीं
करा है। कोई भी अगर वहां पर सिक्योरिटी
सॉल्यूशन क्फ़िगर किया तो वहां पर कोई भी
अलार्म रेज नहीं करेगा। क्योंकि यह एक
कॉमन बात है। यह आम बात है कि आपके पोर्ट
के ऊपर टीसीपी सीन पैकेट के आना था। मतलब
क्या है कि पोर्ट को जैसा चाहिए वैसा यह
पैकेट आपको भेज रहा है आपके पोर्ट को। ठीक
है? दूसरा मेन रीज़न जो प्राइमरी रीज़न है
इसका वो है यह आपका जो थ्री वे हैंडसेक
होता है टीसीपी कनेक्शन के टाइम पर। उस
थ्री वे हैंडसेक को क्या कर रहा है? यह
कंप्लीट नहीं कर रहा। आपने सीन पैकेट
भेजा। यह रिप्लाई रिस्पांस में आपका मिल
रहा है सीन एसी के और वहां पे उसके बदले
में क्या भेज रहा है? एकनॉलेजमेंट पैकेट
की बजाय यह क्या भेज रहा है आपको उसको
रिसेट मतलब मेरे कनेक्शन को क्लोज कर दो
यह कंप्लीट हैंडसेक परफॉर्म कर ही नहीं
रहा और मोस्ट ऑफ द सिक्योरिटी सॉल्यूशन
चाहे आपके फायर वाल्स हैं चाहे आपके
आईडीएस है या आईपीएस है उनको कॉन्फिगर
किया गया है आपके
टीसीp थ्री वे हैंड से कंप्लीट होने के
बाद जब एक बार कनेक्शन क्रिएट हो जाता है
तो उसी की एंट्री उसके लोग में बनाने के
लिए ठीक है तो यह क्या करता है कि आपको
अवॉयड करता है कि जो आपकी फायर वॉल है जो
आपका सिक्योरिटी सॉल्यूशन है या आपकी जो
मशीनंस में जो लोग क्रिएट होते हैं उनके
लोग में एंट्री होने से आपके कनेक्शन की
एंट्री होने से उसको क्या करता है? अवॉइड
करता है। क्योंकि मशीन कंफिगरर्ड है आपकी
90% जो मशीन आज कंफिगरर्ड है सिक्योरिटी
सोलशंस वो क्या करती है? आपके एक बार
कनेक्शन इस्टैब्लिश हो जाए तभी जाके वो
क्या करती है? उसको अपने लॉक में मेंटेन
करती है। मतलब क्या है? आपको अवॉइड कर रहा
है आपके फायर वाल में उसकी एंट्री को भी।
तो दीज़ आर द टू मेजर रीज़ंस इसके स्टिलथियन
होने का एक स्टेफ होने। एवरीवन गॉट
क्लियर?
यस। हाफ स्कैन भी बोल सकते हैं।
एवरीवन गॉट क्लियर? किसी को कोई डाउट है?
आप चाहो तो टीसीp कनेक्ट स्कैन भी खुद से
भेज सकते हो। कैसे एन मैप हफन पी एन उसके
बाद हफन एस और टी कैपिटल टी टीसीp कनेक्ट
स्कैन देन उसके बाद आप भेज सकते हो
192.168.0.19
को मैं जैसे भेज देता हूं। हिट एंटर
तो यहां पर आपको यह इनेशन देखने को मिल
रही होगी। अगर मुझे यूडीपी पोर्ट स्कैन
करने हैं तो उसे भी मैं कर सकता हूं कैसे
10 मैप 51 एसय यूडीपी पोर्ट स्कैन देन
उसके बाद मेरा टारगेट आईपी 1921682
यह रहा
यहां पे मैं क्या कर रहा हूं यूडीपी पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग कर रहा हूं मैं क्या कर रहा हूं
यहां पर यूडीपी पोर्ट स्कैनिंग
श्योर धनंजय वी विल एक्सप्लेन कि हम ओपन
पोर्स के साथ क्या कर सकते हैं। पूरा
कोर्स वही है। तो अभी नहीं बता सकता लेकिन
मैं आपको जैसे-जैसे हम आने वाले टाइम में
जैसे-जैसे बढ़ेंगे नेक्स्ट क्लासेस में तो
मैं आपको बताऊंगा कि ओपन पोस्ट में जो
सर्विज मिलती हैं तो उनके साथ क्या
करेंगे? ओके? तो उनके हम क्या करते हैं?
मैं आपको आईडिया दे देता हूं। हम
वनेबिलिटी असेसमेंट करते हैं। वनेबिलिटी
असेसमेंट में हम फाइंड आउट करने के करने
की कोशिश करते हैं कि यह जो पर्टिकुलर
पोर्ट है या पर्टिकुलर सर्विस है इस पोर्ट
पोर्ट के वो जो रन कर रही है वो वनेबल तो
नहीं है किसी पर्टिकुलर वनेबिलिटी से अगर
वो वनेबल है तो वहां से हम उसको क्या करते
हैं फिर वनेबिलिटी को टेक ओवर करने की
कोशिश करते हैं। दिस इज़ अ टोटल सिनेरियो।
इट विल टेक टाइम। अभी तो 48% हुआ है।
मे बी इधर आपका पोर्ट स्कैनिंग था शायद
आपको अच्छे से समझ में आ गया होगा कि
हॉर्स डिस्कवरी कैसे परफॉर्म करते हैं एन
मैप की हेल्प से पोर्ट स्कैनिंग कैसे
परफॉर्म करते हैं एन मैप की हेल्प से
इट विल टेक टाइम
और यहां पर भी आप क्या कर सकते हो जो आपका
होस्ट डिस्कवरी है एन मैप हफन एन की हेल्प
से क्या कर सकते हो डिस्कवरी को होस्ट पिन
को क्या स्किप करके डायरेक्टली यूडीबी
पोर्ट्स को स्कैन कर सकते हो जिसके बेस पे
आपको ज्यादा फास्ट फास्ट तरीके से रिजल्ट
देखने को मिलेगा। ओके? यह अभी क्या कर रहा
है? पहले होस्ट डिस्कवरी कर रहा है देन
उसके बाद पोर्ट स्कैनिंग कर रहा है। अभी
रिजल्ट आपका 70% हुआ है।
टाइप थ्री में आप डायरेक्टली अपने विंडो
को उड़ा दीजिए और डायरेक्टली कालinx को
यूज कीजिए तो दिस विल बी द बेटर ऑप्शन।
अगर आपको यह पता करना है कि व्हाट इज द
डिफरेंस बिटवीन टीसीपी स्कैन एंड यूडीपी
स्कैन देन फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल यू नीड टू
अंडरस्टैंड द व्हाट इज द डिफरेंस बिटवीन
टीसीपी एंड यूडीपी देन ओनली यू गेट द आंसर
व्हाट इज द डिफरेंस बिटवीन टीसीपी स्कैन
एंड यूडीपी स्कैन तो ये चीज जानने के लिए
आपको मेरे ओएसआई मॉडल से लेके प्रीवियस
क्लासेस में मे बी क्लास डे फाइव या ओके
या डे सेवन डे सेवन में आपको टीसीपी
यूडीपी का डिफरेंस मिल जाएगा कि टीसीपी और
यूडी यूडीपी में क्या डिफरेंस है। तब आपको
यह कांसेप्ट समझ में आएगा टीसीपी और
यूडीपी स्कैन में क्या है? ओके तो यहां पे
यह देखिए आपको यूडीपी स्कैन भी आपको देखने
को मिल रहा है। दीज़ आर द 135 ओपन फ़्टर ओपन
फिल्टर्ड ओपन फिल्टर्ड अभी कौन सा मैंने
यूज़ किया था? 222। ओके? तो, अब यह ओपन और
फ़िल्टर्ड का मतलब क्या आता है? यह भी मैं
आपको बताऊंगा। लेकिन, थोड़ा सा टाइम दीजिए
मुझे। तो, यह था आपका पोर्ट स्कैनिंग। किस
तरीके से आप क्या कर सकते हो? किसी भी
टारगेट के बारे में पोर्ट स्कैनिंग कर
सकते हो। तो अभी आपको आईडिया होगा कि किस
मशीन पे कौन-कौन से पोर्ट ओपन है। अभी
उसके बाद हम नेक्स्ट स्टेप पे जाते हैं जो
हमारा थर्ड स्टेप होता है सर्विस वर्जन
एंड ओएस डिटेक्शन। कौन सा होता है हमारा?
सर्विस वर्जन एंड ओएस डिटेक्शन। अभी जब एक
बार हमारे पास क्या है कि ओपन पोर्स की
इंफॉर्मेशन है देन उसके बाद मैं अपने
सर्विस वर्जन और ओएस डिटेक्शन टॉपिक की
हेल्प से आपको यह सिखाऊंगा कि मैं कैसे
आइडेंटिफाई करूंगा कि इन ओपन पोर्ट्स के
ऊपर कौन सी सर्विस रन कर रही है और इस
सर्विस का वर्जन कौन सा है। यह चीज अभी
मैं आपको सिखाऊंगा कि कौन सी सर्विस रन कर
रही है और इस सर्विस का वर्जन कौन सा है।
अभी व्हाई इट इजेंट?
ये ये सारी की सारी इंफॉर्मेशन जो सर्विस
की इंफॉर्मेशन है या चाहे आपकी सर्विस
वर्जन की इंफॉर्मेशन है आपके काम आती है
वो असेसमेंट के के दौरान जब आप वो
असेसमेंट का स्टेप परफॉर्म करते हैं या
वोमिटी एनालिसिस करते हो या आप थ्रेड
मॉडलिंग करते हो शॉक एनालिस्ट का पार्ट है
ये जब आप थ्रेड मॉडलिंग करते हो तब यह
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन काम आती है सर्विस और
सर्विस वर्जन अभी हम इस इंफॉर्मेशन के
आधार पे क्या करते हैं हम इस इंफॉर्मेशन
के आधार पर यह फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश
करते हैं कि जो यह पर्टिकुलर सर्विस है
मिसकॉन्फिगर तो नहीं है या यह जो सर्विस
है पर्टिकुलर सर्विस सर्विस है किसी
पर्टिकुलर जो वनेबिलिटी है सर्विस वर्जन
के हिसाब से वो वनेबल तो नहीं है कि उसका
हो सकता है कि अभी लेटेस्ट वर्जन कुछ हो
और यह जो हमारी मशीनंस है या जो भी कंपनी
है ऑर्गेनाइजेशन है किसी ऐसे वर्जन को यूज़
कर रही है जिसमें वनेबिलिटी है तो क्या यह
वनेबिलिटी अभी भी एक्सिस्ट करती है क्या
इस सर्विस के अंदर तो यह फाइंड आउट करने
की कोशिश करते और जो ओएस डिटेक्शन की बात
करते हैं, ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के इंफॉर्मेशन
के आधार पर हम यह फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश
करते हैं कि जो आपका ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है,
जो आपका टारगेट ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है, वो
लेटेस्ट जो पैच है, उनसे पैच्च्ड है या
अनपैच्ड है। मतलब लेटेस्ट जो भी
सिक्योरिटी पैचेस आए हैं अभी भी चाहे वो
लinक्स जो ऑपरेटिंग Windows ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम है वो उनसे पैच किया हुआ है या
अनपैच्ड है। अगर वो सिक्योरिटी जो
सिक्योरिटी पैचेस आए हैं उससे अनपैच्ड है।
मतलब क्या है कि उसके अंदर भी वनेबिलिटी
हो सकती है। ठीक है? तो हम उस वनेबिलिटी
के बेस पे क्या करने की कोशिश करेंगे? उस
सिस्टम में एक्सेस गेन करने की कोशिश
करेंगे। तो दिस इज़ द टोटल सिनेरियो ऑफ़ द
सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन एंड द ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम डिटेक्शन। तो दैट इज़ व्हाई मोस्ट
दिस इज़ आल्सो द मोस्ट प्रिपरे स्टेप
सर्विस वर्जन एंड ओएस डिटेक्शन। ओके? तो
इसलिए हम सर्विस वर्जन और ओएस डिटेक्शन
करते हैं। तो यह कैसे करते हैं? मैं आपको
दिखा देता हूं। अभी हमारे पास क्या
पोर्ट्स की इनेशन है? कौन-कौन से पो्स ओपन
है? अभी मुझे इनके ऊपर मैं क्या करूंगा?
सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन करूंगा। सर्विस
वर्जन डिटेक्शन करूंगा। तो मैं सब अभी मैं
जो मेरा टारगेट है कौन सा है? टू टू टू
है। तो मैं अभी एन मैप हफन PN देन उसके
बाद स्टिल स्कैन कर रहा हूं। देन हफन T4
कर रहा हूं मैं। हफन T4 देन उसके बाद मैं
क्या कर रहा हूं? इसके ऊपर
सारे के सारे पोर्ट के ऊपर कर रहा हूं। ऑल
द पोर्ट्स देन 192.168.0
डॉट अभी मैं लिस्ट आउट कर रहा हूं। ओनली
लिस्ट आउट कर रहा हूं। देन उसके बाद मैं
क्या करूंगा? सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन
करूंगा। ओके? इसके बाद मैं क्या करूंगा?
सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन। एक बार मैं आपके
सामने लिस्ट शो कर देता हूं। जितने ओपन
पोर्ट्स हैं। उसके बाद हम क्या करेंगे?
फर्दर यह फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश करेंगे
कि कौन-कौन सी सर्विज रन कर रही है। उस
सर्विस का वर्जन क्या है। अभी आपके सामने
जो देखने को बाय डिफ़ॉल्ट ये क्या कर रहा
है? यह आपको शो कर रहा है कि एक देखो यह
पोर्ट है। पोर्ट की डिटेल है। यह इसकी
स्टेट है। ओपन या क्लोज है। और सर्विस में
इसके बारे में आपको पता चल रहा है कि इसके
ऊपर कौन सी सर्विस रन कर रही है। बाय
डिफ़ॉल्ट तो ये आपको शो कर रहा है। इधर से
देखिए एफटीp एसएसए http एमएसआरपीसी
नेट बायoस Microsoft डीएस मायक्यूएल एंड
डब्ल्यूएस मैन दीज़ ऑल आर द सर्विज रनिंग
ऑन दीज़ पोर्ट्स। बट अभी मैं क्या कर रहा
हूं? सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन। अभी मेरे पास
ओनली क्या है? सर्विस की इनेशन है। लेकिन
मैं यह भी फाइंड आउट करना चाहता हूं कि इस
पर्टिकुलर पोर्ट पे जो सर्विस रन कर रही
है, तो उसका वर्जन कौन सा है? तो यह फाइंड
आउट करने के लिए मैं यूज़ करता हूं अपनी
कमांड में एक फ्लैग यूज़ करता हूं या एक
ऑप्शंस यूज़ करता हूं। कौन सा? एनम मैप
हफन पीएन स्किप होस्ट डिस्कवरी। देन आप
मैं यूज़ कर रहा हूं स्टील स्कैन। देन उसके
बाद मैं यूज कर रहा हूं सर्विस वर्जन
डिटेक्शन एस वी स्मॉल एस कैपिटल वी सर्विस
वर्जन डिटेक्शन यही वो ऑप्शंस है जिसको
मैं यूज़ करूंगा सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन के
लिए देन उसके बाद हफन पी उसके बाद ऑल द
पो्स देन उसके बाद मेरा टारगेट आईपीड है
222 नाउ इट विल टेक टाइम बट इट विल गिव यू
द बेस्ट रिजल्ट
यह साइबर गिक है।
इस टाइप की भाषा का यूज ना करें ग्रुप
में। प्लीज आपसे रिक्वेस्ट है।
अगर आपको बोलने की तमीज नहीं है तो प्लीज
यहां पर मैसेज में ना बोले।
इससे आपको पता चल रहा है कि आपने क्या
सीखा है और कितनी अच्छी-अच्छी चीजें आपके
घर वालों ने आपको सिखाई है। ग्रेट
इट विल टेक टाइम अभी 78% हुआ है यह मेबी
अभी कंप्लीट होने वाला है ना 94%
97% तो कंप्लीट होने वाला है।
यस जो कुलदीप बोल रहा है प्लीज फोकस ऑन द
सेशन आप मैसेज देखिए मत जब मैं आपसे पूछूं
तभी आप बोलिए
ओके अभी यहां से मुझे बहुत सारी इन आपको
देखने देखने को मिल रही है। देखिए यहां पर
एक और कॉलम ऐड हो गया। सर्विस के बाद एक
वर्जन तो पोर्ट 21 पे Microsoft FTPD
सर्विस लेकिन उसका वर्जन अभी भी हमारे पास
कंप्लीटली नहीं आया। लेकिन एसएसएच वर्जन
हमारे पास आ गया ओपन एसएसएस 7.1 Microsoft
iएस एचटीपीडी 7.5 यह Microsoft Windows
RPC नेट बायoस ओके देखिए पोर्ट नंबर 445
पे Microsoft Windows Ser 208 RR2 ओके यह
देखिए
उसके बाद जावा आ रहा है Myesl 5.5.20
लोग मतलब
सर्विज इंफॉर्मेशन आपको सर्विस वर्जन
इनेशन आपको देखने को मिल रही है। साथ के
साथ आपको एक और चीज देखोगे तो यहां पर यह
कुछ ओएस फिंगरप्रिंटिंग भी आपको दे रहा
है। ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की इनेशन देगा। ये
रहा कि इसको लग रहा है कि सर्विस इन
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की Windows ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम है वो भी कौन सा Windows server
208 RR2 2012 ओके तो ये आपको Windows की
इंफॉर्मेशन दे रहा है कि कौन सा ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम इसके ऊपर रन कर रहा है मतलब
Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम तो जो पोर्ट
192.1
सॉरी जो IP एड्रेस है 192.168.2
उसके ऊपर कौन से सर्विस कौन सा ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम रन कर रहा है आपका Windows लेकिन
अभी तक मुझे श्योरिटी नहीं है कि यह
Windows है या नहीं। देखो पोर्ट को देख के
मैं आईडिया लगा सकता हूं कि यह Windows
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है। नाउ फिर भी अगर मैं
चाहता हूं कि मुझे ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की
इनेशन चाहिए कि इसके ऊपर कौन सा ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम रन कर रहा होगा कि ओएस डिटेक्शन
करना है। तो उसके लिए मैं यूज़ कर सकता हूं
एन मैप अभी हफन PN उसके बाद मैं क्या
करूंगा? हफन एस उसके बाद शील्ड स्कैन देन
हफन टी फॉर टाइम फॉर उसके बाद देन मैं यूज़
करने वाला हूं डायरेक्टली अभी मैं डिफॉल्ट
पोर्ट्स पे छोड़ देता हूं डिफॉल्ट पोर्ट
हफन कैपिटल ओ कैपिटल ओ का मतलब आपका क्या
है ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम डिटेक्शन कैपिटल ओ
आपका क्या करता है ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
डिटेक्शन देन उसके बाद में स्पेसिफाई
टारगेट आईपीड 1921 1682
यह देखिए हिट एंटर
अभी इसमें ज्यादा टाइम नहीं लगेगा।
ओके। अभी यहां पर देखिए आपको इंफॉर्मेशन
मिल गई। अभी मैं सर्विस वर्जन तो मैंने
किया नहीं। चलो मैं फिर से सर्विस वर्जन
के साथ और आपके सामने रन करता हूं। चलो।
एंड
मुझे इसकी रैम बढ़ानी होगी। तो मैं नेक्स्ट
सेशन में इसके बढ़ा दूंगा। हफन एस वी
66% हो गया है। डोंट वरी।
गाइस सबको मजा आ रहा
95% हो गया।
गुड अगर आप साथ में प्रैक्टिकल कर रहे हो
तो वेरी गुड।
कोई डीबगिंग करनी आती है तो कीजिए।
अदरवाइज आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा? फिर उसको
बाईपास करने के तरीके ढूंढने होंगे। ओके?
आपको बाईपास करने के तरीके ढूंढने होंगे।
देखिए अभी हम फाइंड आउट करते हैं। देखो
अभी मुझे क्या कहा? मैंने ओएस डिटेक्शन
करना था। तो यह तो था सर्विस वर्जन आपके
सामने ना अभी यह देखिए वन सर्विस
अनरिकॉग्नाइज ओके ओके ओके सो सो यह आपका
क्या कर रहा है कुछ फिंगरप्रिंटिंग है और
आपको बता रहा है यह देखो moft windows 7
208.1 यह इंफॉर्मेशन आपको बता रहा है जो
इसको देखने को मिल रही है। देन यह रहा
सर्विस इंफॉर्मेशन आपको बता रहा है जो यह
है आपका Windows सर्वर 208 R2 2012 यही
इंफॉर्मेशन आपको देखने को मिल रही है। अभी
आप चाहते हो नहीं मुझे क्या करना ओनली
ओनली फोकस करके मुझे एग्रेसिवली या
एक्सप्लसिटली बोल सकते हो या एग्रेसिवली
बोल सकते हो मुझे नहीं ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की
और ज्यादा एग्जैक्ट इनेशन चाहिए मुझे और
ज्यादा मतलब कि एग्रेसिव वे में कि मुझे
ज्यादा थोड़ी सी और करेक्ट थोड़ा और
करेक्ट चाहिए क्योंकि यहां पर इनफेशन आपको
आईडिया मिल रहा है कि ओके वindows सर्वर
काम कर लेकिन कहीं पर आप ऐसे भी केस हो गए
जहां पर आपको कि फिर भी समझ में नहीं आ
रहा हो कि Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है
लinक्स ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम उस केस में क्या
करते हो एग्रेसिव स्कैनिंग करते हो। और जब
एग्रेसिव स्कैनिंग करते हो तो आप क्या
करते? आपके जो आउटपुट जो रिजल्ट के जो
करेक्टनेस है कि आउटपुट सही होने के
चांसेस वो बढ़ जाते हैं। तो उसके लिए आप
यूज़ करते हो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की एग्रेसिव
स्कैनिंग के लिए आप यूज करते हो एस ओ ओके
एन मैप हफन पी एन उसके बाद आप यूज़ करते हो
अह हफन
और एसएस स्टील स्कैन हफन T4 उसके बाद देन
मैं यूज़ कर रहा हूं hन ओ ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
डिटेक्शन देन उसके बाद हफन हफन
ओ एस
स्कैन ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम स्कैन हफन गैस जी
यू ई एस एस गैस यह एग्रेसिव स्कैनिंग के
लिए यूज़ किया जाता है। हफन पोर्ट में
मेंशन नहीं करना तो मैं डिफॉल्ट पोर्ट ही
छोड़ देता हूं। या अगर मुझे सभी पोर्ट्स
को मेंशन करना चाहता हूं तो वो भी मैं कर
सकता हूं। तो देन उसके बाद टारगेट IPपी
एड्रेस 192.168.0.22
मे बी देखो स्किप द होस्ट डिस्कवरी ओके
सेंड टीसीपी सिम पैकेट यह टाइम परफॉर्मेंस
के लिए यूज़ करते हैं। आई विल एक्सप्लेन इन
लेटर ऑन द क्लास मे बी नेक्स्ट क्लास।
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम डिटेक्शन एंड मोर
एग्रेसिवली ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम डिटेक्शन। नाउ
हिट एंटर देखिए।
अश्विन्या जी आई विल एक्सप्लेन
डोंट वरी
कोई इशू नहीं मुझे बेसिकली क्या करना है
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के बारे में ज्यादा
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करनी है तो चलो मैं
आपके लिए ऐड भी कर देता हूं
हेलो
अगर मैं चाहे तो टारगेट भी बदल सकता हूं।
तो जरूरी नहीं इसी टारगेट पे परफॉर्म करूं
क्योंकि मुझे इसका आईडिया होगा कि इसमें
Windows सर्वर 208 ही रन कर रहा है। तो इट
इज़ एग्जैक्ट और करेक्ट इनेशन। तो मोर
एग्रेसिवली अगर मैं किसी दूसरे ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम पे परफॉर्म करना चाहता हूं वह भी
मैं कर सकता हूं।
नाउ इट विल टेक 71% नाउ डोंट वरी
आप चाहो तो एक काम कर सकते हो कि एक
चिटशीट अवेलेबल्स है आपके इंटरनेट पे आप
उसको फॉलो कर सकते हो। फॉर एग्जांपल दिस
इज़ द चिट ऑफ़ अवेलेबल। यह रही nmap चिटशीट
है। यह पीडीएफ आप चाहो तो एक है यह एनमप
चिट एंड उसके बाद स्टेन स्टेशन एक्स सर्च
करोगे तो वहां पर आपको देखने को मिल
जाएगी। तो काफी अच्छी चिटशीट अवेलेबल है
जो आप यूज कर सकते हो ड्यूरिंग योर एग्जाम
खास करके जब पेन टेस्टिंग एग्जाम दोगे या
आप अपने फ्यूचर्स में कभी भी आप पेन
टेस्टिंग कर रहे हो तो दिस इज अ वेरी गुड
चिटशीट इन हर एक ऑप्शंस को काफी डिटेल्स
में एक्सप्लेन किया है तो जो अभी हम
परफॉर्म कर रहे हैं सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन
दिया था ये रहा hन sv hfन s मैंने अभी
यूज़ किया था ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम देखो hन ओ
यह ओs कैन गेस मतलब क्या करता है मेक्स
एनमप गैस मोर एग्रेसिवली मेक एनप गैस मोर
एग्रेसिवली। तो ये चिट आप क्या कर सकते
हो? खुद भी डाउनलोड कर सकते हो। कैसे आप
सिंपली आपको क्या करना है कि nap
चिट
और स्टेशन एक्स
ये रहा। सर्च करोगे। यहां पर जाओगे तो आप
क्या कर सकते हो? डाउनलोड कर सकते हो
सिंपली एन मैप की चिटशीट और काफी हेल्पफुल
रहेगी आपके किसी भी पेन टेस्टिंग जर्नी
में नाउ। ओके? तो हमारा स्कैन कंप्लीट हो
गया। तो दिस इज द ओके स्कैन देखो यहां से
आपको पता चल जाएगा यह रहा सर्विस इफ यू ऑन
सर्विस वर्जन सो इन्होंने यूज़ किया अपने
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग नाउ रनिंग Microsoft
Windows टाइप सो दिस इज़ द सर्विस पैक वन
एंड Microsoft Windows 7 एंड ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम डिटेल्स क्या है कि Microsoft
Windows 7 सर्विस पैक ज़ीरो टू वन Windows
सर्वर 208 सर्विस पैक वन Windows सर्वर
208 8 R2 Windows सर्वर यह सारी इनेशन दे
रहा है आपको और बेसिकली यह क्या है? एक
Windows सर्वर ही है। तो मतलब इतना इनेशन
आपको कह कि यह Windows सर्वर यूज़ हो रहा
है इसके ऊपर। अगर मैं किसी और दूसरे
टारगेट पे करना चाहूं तो वो भी कर सकता
हूं। देखिए अभी फॉर एग्जांपल मैं अभी
टारगेट चेंज कर देता हूं। 181
मे बी 181 है या ओके।
नाउ हिट एंटर
इट विल टेक टाइम अगर एक और एक और
इंपॉर्टेंट स्टेप बता देता हूं इसमें अगर
आप क्या करना चाहते हो कि सर्विस वर्जन
आपको एग्जैक्ट सर्विस वर्जन नहीं मिला
जैसे आपने देखा था कि कुछ जो एफटीपी है
कमांड उसका सर्विस वर्जन एग्जैक्ट आपको
देखो यहां पे इसने बताया यहां पर यहां पर
गेस किया देखो एग्रेसिव ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
गैसेस लinक्स 3.2 यह लinक्स कर्नल का
वर्जन है। इसके 98% चांसेस है कि यह
लinक्स कर्नल है। दिस लinक्स कर्नल दिस इज़
अ 94% मतलब मैक्सिमम चांसेस क्या है इसके
98% कि लinक्स कर्नल 3.2 से 4.9 के बीच
में हो सकता है। ओके? Linux ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम है। लेकिन सर्विस इनेशन में देखोगे
आप उबू है यह। उबू ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है यह
दूसरा और कौन सा आईपी एड्रेस है? 181 इसके
ऊपर कौन-कौन सी सर्विज रन कर रही है?
टीसीp एफटीपी एसएसएच एचटीटीपी आईपीपी पीपी
तो देखिए मायसक्यूएल एंड जेटी इसका यह
वर्जन है और प्रो एफटीपीडी 1.3.5
अभी यहां पर क्या है कि सर्विस वर्जन
एग्जैक्टली आपको पता चल गया है। फिर भी
अगर आप क्या चाहते हो कि अगर आपको मोर
एग्रेसिवली करना है कि ओनली सर्विस वर्जन
को ज्यादा करेक्ट वे में फाइंड आउट करना
है कि आप चाहते हो कि यानी सर्विस वर्जन
है मुझे अभी अह थोड़ा आई एम नॉट सेटिस्फाई
या मुझे और ज्यादा कंफर्म करना चाहता हूं।
किसी की जैसे कि मैंने लास्ट क्लास लास्ट
उसमें देखा होगा टू टू जो यह था इस पे जब
हमने मोर जब आप हमने सर्विस वर्जन
डिटेक्शन किया था तो कुछ सर्विज की इनेशन
नहीं आई थी। अगर मैं सर्विज को मोर
एग्रेसिवली करना चाहता हूं तो उसके लिए हम
यूज़ करेंगे एन मैप हफन अभी मैं पूरी कमांड
ही वो कर देता हूं।
उसके लिए भी कमांड होती है एन मैप हफन मैं
क्या करता हूं अभी मोर एग्रेसिवली कर देता
हूं। हो एक्स के लिए मैं हफन पी एन अभी
नहीं कर रहा मैं डायरेक्टली कर लेता हूं
hfन सर्विस सिल स्कैन देन उसके बाद सर्विस
वर्जन डिटेक्शन देन उसके बाद हफन हफन
वर्जन इंटेंसिटी आई एन टी ई एन एस आई टी
वाई वर्जन इंटेंसिटी
एंड उसके बाद एट ये ज़ीरो से लेके नाइन तक
आप सेट कर सकते हो। इसका मतलब क्या होता
है? मैं आपको बता देता हूं। देखिए वर्जन
इंटेंसिटी का मतलब क्या होता है? यह
देखोगे अगर आप चैट शीट के अंदर तो यह रहा
एंड यह रहा वर्जन इंटेंसिटी वर्जन लाइट
वर्जन ऑल वर्जन इंटेंसिटी जीरो से नाइन तक
होती है हायर नंबर इनक्रीज पॉसिबिलिटी ऑफ
करेक्टनेस ओके एंड अगर वर्जन लाइट का यूज़
करोगे तो इनेबल लाइट मोड लोअर पॉसिबिलिटी
ऑफ़ करेक्टनेस लेकिन फास्टर वर्जन ऑल का
मतलब क्या होता है? इनेबल इंटेंसिटी लेवल
नाइन हायर पॉसिबिलिटी ऑफ़ करेक्टनेस लेकिन
यह स्लो काम करेगा। तभी मैं यूज़ कर रहा
हूं इंटेंसिटी 8 यूज़ कर रहा हूं। तो उसके
लिए मैं कैसे यूज़ करूंगा? यह देखिए
वर्जन इंटेंसिटी 8 देन उसके बाद मैं क्या
कर रहा हूं? ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम डिटेक्शन भी
यूज़ कर रहा हूं। ओ देन उसके बाद यह भी
अग्रेसिवली कर रहा हूं। और इसकी मुझे अभी
जरूरत नहीं है। चलो मैं ओनली सर्विस वर्जन
को ही करना चाह रहा हूं। देन हफन पी ऑल
पोर्ट्स एंड 192.168.02.2
उसके बाद हफन T4 यूज़ कर लेते हैं अभी
इसमें एक बार सो दैट आपका जो है स्कैन
थोड़ा जल्दी हो जाए।
हफन T4
नाउ और हिट एंटर कर देते हैं इसको।
आर्यन आप मेरे को Lindin पे मैसेज करो।
नाउ इट्स ओके 64 कंप्लीट हो गया तो सर्विस
वर्जन और ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम डिटेक्शन सबको आ
गया।
थैंक यू हर्षल। अगर आपको लगता है कि इज़ अ
यूज़फुल रिसोर्सेज तो देन जहां पर आप पढ़
रहे थे, आपको लगता है तो मैक्सिमम
स्टूडेंट्स के पास इसको स्प्रेड कीजिए। सो
दैट कि
सबको बेनिफिट मिले।
रसल आपको उसके लिए प्रिपरेशन करने की
जरूरत नहीं है। यू कैन डायरेक्टली अटेंड द
सीएस प्रैक्टिकल नो इशू
यू कैन डायरेक्टली अटेंड
इफ यू नीड एनी हेल्प व्हाट टाइप ऑफ
क्वेश्चन दे कैन कम तो देन आई विल
डेफिनेटली हेल्प यू
बट नॉट ऑन द YouTube
इट इज़ 88.10
नो इशू कंप्लीट होने वाला है। देन उसके
बाद मैं आपको थर्ड टॉपिक जो पढ़ाऊंगा वो
आपको पढ़ाऊंगा फायर वाल डिटेक्शन एंड
आईडीएस इवेज
एंड डिटेक्शन सिस्टम इवेज दिस इज द टुडेज
लास्ट एंड मोस्ट इंपोर्टेंट टॉपिक
मेरे Lindin प्रोफाइल पे अभी मैंने आपको
दिखाया था यहां पर दिस इज माय Lindin
अकाउंट
दिस इज माय Lindin अकाउंट
कई बार डिपेंड करता है कि आपको एग्जैक्ट
वर्जन भी मिल जाता है और कई बार आपका रफ
आईडिया मिलता है बेसिकली।
क्योंकि एनमप के अंदर क्या है कि
फिंगरप्रिंट है हर एक ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के
हर एक वर्जन के उनको मैच करता है और उनके
बेस पे आपको गेस करके बताता है।
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग तो हमेशा स्लो ही होती
है ब्रो।
इट विल टेक टाइम देन उसके बाद नेक्स्ट
टॉपिक पे हम जाएंगे। ज्यादा टाइम नहीं
लेंगे उसमें हार्डली 20 मिनट 90%48
इट विल स्कैन योर कंप्लीट देन वी विल गो
टू फायर वाल डिटेक्शन एंड
आपका आईडीएस इवजन
यस एनमप से एनुमिशन भी कर सकते हो और
एनुमिशन आप डिपेंड करता है किस टाइप की
सर्विस तो सर्विस के बेस पे भी टूल्स
अवेलेबल्स हैं और आप मेटास्प्लेट से भी
एनुमिशन कर सकते हो और दिस इज़ योर अपकमिंग
टॉपिक इन द सेक्शन थ्री सबसे पहले आपको
मेटास्प्लेट के बारे में मैं सिखाऊंगा देन
उसके बाद एनुमरेशन दिखाएंगे। ओके? डोंट
वरी।
अभी बता दिया ना आगे। आगे इंटरेस्ट आपका
बढ़ेगा। कम नहीं होगा।
7:00 पी.m. आईएसटी इंडियन स्टैंडर्ड टाइम
पे स्टार्ट होती है आपकी क्लासेस। डेली
नहीं होती। हर सेकंड या थर्ड डे रहती है।
जहां पर आपको इसके नोटिफिकेशन जो मिलते
हैं आपके WhatsApp चैनल पर मिलते हैं।
डेफोनिक्स के WhatsApp चैनल पर
साइबर एथिक्स अभी टॉपिक ना छोड़िए। जब
इनका टाइम आएगा तो इनको भी एक्सप्लेन कर
देंगे।
तो कभी सेपरेट वीडियो बनानी पड़ गई तो आई
विल डेफिनेटली मेक द वीडियो।
ओके यहां पर देखिए
अभी एग्रेसिवली स्कैन किया तो अभी यहां पर
फिर भी क्या है कि जो पोर्ट एफटीp है
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट एफटीपीडी है उसका वर्जन
डिटेक्ट अभी भी नहीं कर पाया और दीज़ आर एज
इट इज़ है जैसे नाउ कोबरा नेमिंग सर्विस
एंड jवा मैसेज सर्विस 301 HTPD सनग्लास
फिश ओपन सोर्स एडिशन 4.0 Apache टॉम कैट
JSP इंजन 1.1 अपाचे HTTPD तो यह था आपका
सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन एंड ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम डिटेक्शन। तो इसके बाद मुझे नहीं
लगता आपको होस्ट डिस्कवरी और सर्विस वर्जन
डिटेक्शन और पोर्ट स्कैनिंग में कोई डाउट
होना चाहिए। कभी भी आपको अगर कोई भी
टारगेट मिलेगा जहां पर आपको स्कैनिंग
परफॉर्म करनी होगी और जहां पर आपको एनमप
को यूज़ करना होगा तो मुझे नहीं लगता आपको
कोई भी डाउट होना चाहिए। आप उच्च चिटशीट
की हेल्प से और मेरी सिखाई हुई टेक्निक की
हेल्प से किए गए एक्सप्लेनेशन की हेल्प से
आप क्या कर सकते हो फ्यूचर में कभी भी एंड
मैप को यूज़ कर सकते हो और इट इज अ वेरी
हेल्पफुल और पावरफुल टूल्स ड्यूरिंग योर
पेंटेस्टिंग जर्नी इवन चाहे वो रियल लाइफ
हो चाहे वो सीटीएफ हो वेरी वेरी वेरी
हेल्पफुल ओके तो प्लीज अगर आपको समझ में
नहीं आया है तो प्लीज डाउट पूछ लीजिए
अदरवाइज आप रिवाइज कर लीजिए वीडियो
क्लासेस से और जो चीट सिस्टम आपको
प्रोवाइड की है उसको आप एज ए बुकमार्क या
रखिए अपने सिस्टम के अंदर क्योंकि हमेशा
आपको हेल्प करेगी लाइफ में पेन टेस्टिंग
में चाहे आप प्रोफेशनल हो जाओ चाहे कहीं
पर भी मैं हमेशा उसी चीटिट को फॉलो करता
हूं
बताऊंगा वो भी क्या करता है साइबर एथिक्स
अभी एक क्लास और बची हुई है नाउ अभी जो
हमारा टॉपिक है फायर वाल डिटेक्शन एंड
आईडीएस इवेज अभी इसमें हम दो चीज पढ़ने
वाले हैं। एक तो फाइव वाल डिटेक्शन और एक
आईडीएस इवेज के बारे में। देखिए देखो अब
मैं आपको सिखाऊंगा
फाइव इवेज के पाइवल डिटेक्शन और ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम जो आईडीएस इवेज के अंदर जो मेरा
ऑब्जेक्टिव है वो है कि मैं एनमप की हेल्प
से आपको कि यह सिखाऊंगा कि जो आपका होस्ट
है जो आपका सिस्टम है जो आपका सर्वर्स है
कि उस पे आप कैसे डिटेक्ट कर सकते हो कि
प्रेजेंस ऑफ ए फायर वाल कि उसके ऊपर कोई
फ़्टर या कोई फायर वाल मैकेनिज्म अप्लाई
हुआ है या नहीं है उसकी की प्रेजेंस एनम
मैप की हेल्प से आप कैसे फाइंड आउट कर
सकते हो वो मैं आपको बताऊंगा। दूसरा हम
सीखेंगे कि एनम मैप को कैसे यूटिलाइज
करेंगे कि इंट्रोजन डिटेक्शन से से इवड
करने के लिए या कोई भी जो इंट्रोजन
डिटेक्शन के अंदर जो अलार्म रेज ना हो
ड्यूरिंग पोर्ट स्कैनिंग या ड्यूरिंग
स्कैनिंग कोई अलार्म रेज ना हो उसको अवॉइड
करना। तो ये दोनों चीज हम सीखने वाले हैं।
किसके अंदर? अभी फाइव डिटेक्शन एंड
आईडीएससी।
फिर से बता देता हूं। फायर वाव डिटेक्शन
के अंदर हम सिर्फ यह डिटेक्ट करना सीखेंगे
कि ओके कि होस्ट के ऊपर कोई फायर वाल लगी
है या नहीं है। तो वो मैं कैसे पता कर
सकता हूं। ठीक है? वो हम फाइंड आउट करना
सीख लेंगे एनमप की हेल्प से। दूसरा क्या
है कि इवेजन टेक्निक्स कि एनमैप का कैसे
यूज़ करूंगा मैं कि उस टेक्निक से इवेज
करने के लिए आईडीएस से बाईपास करने के
लिए। ओके? ताकि मेरा कोई जो उसके इंटरनल
डिटेक्शन सिस्टम उसके अंदर मेरा मेरे
अगेंस्ट कोई भी अलार्म रेज ना हो। मेरे
स्कैनिंग से अगेंस्ट कि कोई मेरे को स्कैन
कर रहा है। ओके? दीज़ आर द टू वेज़। तो फाइव
डिटेक्शन सबसे पहले सीखते हैं। तो फाइव
डिटेक्शन में सबसे पहले मैं क्या करता
हूं? देखिए कि अभी मैं मैं टारगेट चेंज कर
लेता हूं। क्लियर नाउ अभी एन मैप देन उसके
बाद मैं चाहता हूं hन डिसेबल पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग ना डिसेबल आपका होस्ट डिस्कवरी।
उसके बाद स्किन सिंस स्कैन करना चाहता
हूं। सिंस स्कैन देन उसके बाद हफन स्कैन
और मेरा IPपी एड्रेस क्या है? मेरा IPपी
एड्रेस है 192.18
0.181 यह मेरा IPपी एड्रेस है अभी के लिए
और मैंने हिट एंटर किया।
पीएन का मतलब मैं आपको बता देता हूं। चलो
आपको ऐसे समझ में नहीं आ रहा होगा। देखो
यह रहा
यह रही चीटशीट। यह रही पीएन आपको दिखा। यह
रहा पीए डिसेबल होस्ट डिस्कवरी ओनली पोर्ट
स्कैन। देन उसके बाद मैं मेंशन कर रहा हूं
कि मैं आईसीएमपी यूज़ करूंगा या
पीसीपीसी पैकेट। नाउ यह देखिए यहां पर
आपने एक चीज देखी होगी 181 के अंदर कि
होस्ट इज अप
92 फिल्टर्ड टीसीपी पोर्ट्स 92 फिल्टर्ड
टीसीपी पोर्ट्स देन उसके बाद देखिए दीज़ आर
द ओपन पोर्ट्स एंड क्लोज पोर्ट्स देखिए
अभी यहां पर फिल्टर्ड पोर्ट का मतलब क्या
है देखो फिल्टर्ड टीसीपी पोर्ट्स अगर आपको
इस तरीके से आपको देखने को मिलता है किसके
अंदर एन मैप के अंदर तो इसका मतलब मतलब है
डेफिनेटली यहां पर कुछ यहां पर कोई भी
फायर वाल कॉन्फ़िगर है। वेब बेस्ड फायर वाल
कॉन्फ़िगर है या कोई रूल कॉन्फ़िगरर्ड है या
कोई फिल्टर कॉन्फ़िगर है जो आपको स्कैनिंग
करने से रोक रहा है जो आपको पिन करने से
रोक रहा है या पोर्ट स्कैनिंग करने से रोक
रहा है। मतलब यहां पर कोई ना कोई फायर वाल
या कोई ना कोई सिक्योरिटी सॉल्यूशन
कंफिगरर्ड है। इसका मतलब यहां पर है। ओके?
ठीक है? अगर यहां पर डायरेक्टली फिल्टर
आपको डायरेक्टली देखने को मिल गया। अभी
मैं अगर विंडो के केस में चलो मैं अभी
विंडो का टारगेट लेता हूं। फॉर एग्जांपल
104 ये रहा। इसमें देख लिए
अगर आपको फिल्टर्ड देखने को मिलता है तभी
उसी केस में। ठीक है? तभी उसी केस में
आपको देखने को मिलेगा। नाउ यह देखिए यहां
पर 99 फ़्टर्ड टीसीपी पोर्ट्स एंड वन इज
ओपन पोर्स। अभी एक तो तरीका यह है फाइंड
आउट करने का। ठीक है? एक तरीका यह है।
दूसरा मैं कैसे ज्यादा क्लेरिटी ले सकता
हूं? ज्यादा क्लेरिटी के लिए मैं यूज़ करता
हूं एन मैप हफन पीएन डिसेबल होस्ट
डिस्कवरी हफन एस और एस ए का मतलब क्या
होता है? टीसीपी एसी के स्कैन। टीसीपी एसी
के स्कैन मतलब मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं। ये
रहा हफन एस अभी तक मैंने आपको नहीं बताया
था। लेकिन आपको बता देता हूं। यह रहा एसए
टीसीपी एसी के पोर्ट स्कैन करूंगा। टीसीपी
एसी के पोर्ट स्कैन क्या होगा? देखिए आपके
मैं इसके अंदर बता देता हूं। टीसीपी एसी
के हफन एस ए
यह रहा। यह एसी के पैकेट भेजेगा पोर्ट के
ऊपर और वहां से रिप्लाई में आपका आना
चाहिए आर एसटी पैकेट। वहां पे आपके
रिप्लाई में क्या आना चाहिए? आरएसटी
पैकेट। ओके? हम टीसीपी कौन सा? एसी के
पैकेट। देन उसके बाद मैं मेंशन करता हूं।
फॉर एग्जांपल मैं अब पर्टिकुलर पोर्ट ही
फाइंड आउट करना पी देन मेरा पोर्ट नंबर
39 उसके बाद 8080
देन 192.168.0
डॉट अभी मैं IP एड्रेस ले रहा हूं। 159
फ़ॉर एग्ज़ांपल 159 नहीं मैं 15 अम 81 लेता
हूं। चलो 181 ले लेता हूं। हिट एंटर देखिए
ओनली तीन पोर्ट देखिए 139 फिल्टर्ड एंड
बाकी अनफिल्टर्ड अनफिल्टर्ड मतलब यहां पर
मतलब अभी फिल्टर्ड आ गया मतलब यहां पर
क्या है आपका फायर बॉल डिफर नहीं कर अगर
यहां आपको अनफिल्टर्ड देखने को मिलता है
ओपन मिलता है और ऊपर जैसे कि मैं कहां पे
बता देता हूं यह रहा 160 कर देता हूं 160
यह रहा अनफिल्टर्ड नेट बायस अभी मैं 160
को फिर से स्कैन अभी मैं डिफ़ॉल्ट पोर्ट
छोड़ देता हूं देखिए स्कैन करूंगा मैं।
एंड एंड एंड एंड वेट वेट वेट वेट वेट वेट
क्लियर एन मैप हफन
पीए
स्टिल स्कैन देन हफन स्कैन देन उसके बाद
मैं क्या कर रहा हूं? 192.168.0.160
दिस इज माय टारगेट माय खुद की मशीन का।
यहां पर आपको क्या देखने को मिल रहा है?
100 क्लोज पो्स अभी यहां पर ना तो कोई
फिल्टर्ड है ना ही यहां पर कोई अनफिल्टर्ड
है। मतलब यहां पर इसका मतलब क्या है? यहां
पर कोई भी फायर वाल कॉन्फ़िगर नहीं है। तो
आपको मैंने बता दिया कि आपको कि कैसे पता
चलेगा कि यहां पर कोई भी फायर वाल
कॉन्फ़िगर है या कोई भी फ़्टर कॉन्फ़िगर है
जो आपके रिक्वेस्ट को ब्लॉक कर रहा है।
प्रोब रिक्वेस्ट को ब्लॉक कर रहा है। तो
उसका तरीका यही है कि आपको यहां पर फ़्टर्ड
देखने को मिलेगा। फिल्टर्ड आपको देखने को
मिलेगा। ओके? तो आपको पता चल गया कैसे आप
फाइंड आउट कर सकते हो कि आपके जो होस्ट
हैं आपके सबनेट के अंदर उनके ऊपर फायबल
कॉन्फिगरर्ड है या नहीं है। एवरीवन गॉट
क्लियर?
एवरीवन गॉट क्लियर?
स्टिल कोई किसी का डाउट है?
ओके नेक्स्ट अब हम बात करते हैं आईडीएस
इवेज टेक्निक के बारे में। एंड वन ऑफ द
मोस्ट यूज्ड टेक्निक एंड वन ऑफ द बेस्ट
टेक्निक दैट यू कैन यूटिलाइज टू इवेट
इंट्रोजन डिटेक्शन सिस्टम और टू मेक इट
हार्डर फॉर द
डायरेक्ट
एक्टिविटी लाइक पोर्ट स्कैन। ठीक है?
डिटेक्ट सॉरी
देखिए आपको समझ में नहीं आया होगा क्योंकि
मैंने कहीं पर नोट्स बनाया हुआ है। मैंने
सिर्फ उसको आपके देख के बताया भी। देखिए
एक इंपॉर्टेंट एक बहुत ही इंपॉर्टेंट
मोस्ट पॉपुलर टेक्निक है। आईडीएस इवजन के
लिए जो यूज की जाती है। इवजन के लिए यूज़
की जाती है। वह है आपकी
फ्रेगमेंटेशन ऑफ पैकेट। कौन सा है?
फ्रेगमेंटेशन ऑफ पैकेट्स। मतलब
फ्रेगमेंटेशन एक ऐसी टेक्निक होती है आपके
नेटवर्क के अंदर जिसमें आप क्या कर सकते
हो? अपने टीसीपी पैकेट्स को स्मॉलस्मॉल
पैकेट्स में स्मॉल स्ट्रंग्स ऑफ डेटा या
स्मॉल पैकेट्स में क्या कर सकते हो?
कन्वर्ट करके भेज सकते हो। ठीक है? जिससे
क्या होगा? आपका जो आईडीएस है, वह क्या
करेगा? डिटेक्ट नहीं कर पाएगा। आप क्या
करोगे? फ्रेगमेंटेशन टेक्निक का यूज़ करके।
कैसे करोगे? उसके लिए होती है एन मैप।
फिर से मैं बता देता हूं आपकी जो टेक्निक
यूज की जाती है आईडीएस डिटेक्शन के लिए
इवेट करने के लिए वह होती है आपकी
फ्रेगमेंटेशन ऑफ पैकेट। फ्रेगमेंटेशन का
मतलब होता है कि जो आपके पैकेट है जो
टीसीपी पैकेट आप प्रोप पैकेट को भेजने
वाले हैं उनको क्या कर डायरेक्टली सिंगल
पैकेट ना भेज के उनको छोटे-छोटे पैकेट में
कन्वर्ट करके भेज सकते हो। ओके? तो उसके
वो कैसे भेज सकते हो? एनमप हफन पीएन देन
उसके बाद हफन एसएस स्टिल स्कैन देन उसके
बाद मैं यूज़ कर रहा हूं सर्विस वर्जन
डिटेक्शन सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन देन हफन
कैपिटल एफ फास्ट स्कैन हफन स्मॉल एफ मतलब
मैं क्या कर रहा हूं अभी फ्रेगमेंटेड
पैकेट मुझे क्या करना है कि पूरे पैकेट को
एक साथ नहीं भेजना मुझे फ्रेगमेंटेड भेजना
है छोटे-छोटे पैकेट में कन्वर्ट करके
भेजना है एन मैप के पैकेट को देन उसके बाद
मैं मेंशन करता हूं 192 डॉट
168.02.22
[संगीत]
हिट एंटर फिर से बता देता हूं।
स्किप द होस्ट डिस्कवरी सिंस कैन सर्विस
वर्जन डिटेक्शन स्कैन उसके बाद
फ्रेगमेंटेड
आपके पैकेट को क्या करना है? फ्रेगमेंट
में छोटे-छोटे पैकेट में कन्वर्ट करके
भेजना है और डायरेक्टली हिट एंटर। देखिए
यह रहा।
तो समझ में आ गया फ्रेगमेंटेशन का मतलब
क्या है और यह टेक्निक क्या है कि आप क्या
कर रहे हो टीसीपी पैकेट को छोटे-छोटे
पैकेट में भेज रहे हो एक साथ ना भेजें
जिससे क्या होगा कि अभी आपके जो मशीन है
जैसे एनएफ स्कैन है अटैकर की मशीन से
छोटे-छोटे पैकेट में जा रहा और जो आपका
सर्वर्स है जो क्लाइंट है टारगेट है उसकी
मशीन पे रिसीव होकर उसको रीअेंबल किया जा
रहा है। रिअसेंबल करके उसका फिर रिस्पांस
भेज रहे हैं। तो इससे भी क्या है आपका
आईडीएस है वह डिटेक्ट नहीं कर पाएगा।
एक एक टेक्निक यह है आपकी इवेट इवेज
टेक्निक
78% तो इट विल टेक टाइम बट डेफिनेटली इट
यह सारी चीजें जब आप परफॉर्म कर रहे हो ना
आप साथ में अपने क्या बोलते हैं वायरस को
ऑन कीजिए और वहां पर देखते रहिए कि आपका
एनमप कैसे किस वे में डेटा को भेज रहा है
फ्रेगमेंटेड और नॉन फ्रेगमेंटेड उस तरीके
से फिर ठीक है अभी देखना यहां पर यह रहा
तो सक्सेसफुली रिजल्ट आपको देखने को मिल
रहा नाउ यह रहा। यह पहले से आपको आपके पास
इंफॉर्मेशन थी तो वही सेम इंफॉर्मेशन इसने
अभी आपके सामने शो की है। ओके तो एक तो
तरीका यह है आपका आईडीएस इवजन को इवेट
करने का। दूसरा एक और तरीका है जो आप यूज़
करते हो। एक टेक्निक है डिकॉय आईपी एड्रेस
भेज के मतलब स्पुप्ड आईपी एड्रेस भेज के।
स्पुप आईपी एड्रेस भेज सके। डिकॉय आईपी हम
जिसको बोल सकते हैं स्पूप आईपी एड्रेस
मतलब क्या है कि
आप अपना आईपी एड्रेस ना भेज के वो आईपी
एड्रेस इसके अंदर मेंशन करोगे जो उनके
नेटवर्क में दिखने चाहिए। ओके अभी फॉर
एग्जांपल मैंने इफ कॉन्फिग किया। इफ
कॉन्फिग करता हूं। अभी यहां पर मैं मेरा
IPपी एड्रेस कौन सा है? 192.1680.160
मैं इससे बेटर टेक्निक बताता हूं आपको
डेको आईपी वाली। ओके? 160 हो गया। तो मतलब
क्या है कि मैं उसी नेटवर्क से कनेक्टेड
हूं। कौन से नेटवर्क से कनेक्टेड हूं
जिसको मैं पेन टेस्ट कर रहा हूं। तो मैं
क्या कर सकता हूं कि अभी फॉर एग्जांपल जो
अपोजिट साइड में जो टारगेट सिस्टम है उसके
ऊपर क्या है कि शॉक एनालिस्ट काम कर रही
है। नेटवर्क एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर काम कर रहा है
और साथ के साथ जो सिक्योरिटी रिस्चरर्स
हैं, जो सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर्स हैं, वह भी
काम कर रहे हैं। और कंटीन्यूअसली वो क्या
कर रहे नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक को मॉनिटर कर रहे
हैं। वो कंटीन्यूअसली नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक को
मॉनिटर कर रहे हैं। लेकिन एक चीज आपको पता
है अगर नहीं पता तो मैं आपको बता देता हूं
कि किसी भी सबनेट के अंदर जो फर्स्ट IPपी
एड्रेस होता है जैसे कि यह सबनेट कौन सा
है? 255.255.25
जिसका क्या है? IPपी रेंज कौन सा है?
192.168.0
है। इसका जो पहला IPपी एड्रेस होगा हमेशा
वो क्या होता है? गेटवे IP एड्रेस होता
है। पहला IPपी एड्रेस कौन सा होता है
आपका? हमेशा गेटवे IP एड्रेस होता है। अभी
क्यों ना मैं ऐसे ऐसा करूं कि जो भी शॉक
एनालिस्ट उस नेटवर्क को मॉनिटर कर रही है
या जो भी नेटवर्क एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर उस
नेटवर्क को मॉनिटर कर रहा है या चाहे
सिक्योरिटी रिसर्च है या सिक्योरिटी
इंजीनियर है चाहे वहां पर जो भी टीम आपके
नेटवर्क को मॉनिटर कर रही है। क्यों ना
मैं उनको यह शो करवाऊं कि जो पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग रिक्वेस्ट आ रही है जो एनम मैप
की स्कैनिंग रिक्वेस्ट आ रही है वह मेरे
अटैकर के पीसी के बजाय वो आपके गेटवे से आ
रही है। मतलब जो पोर्ट की जो स्कैनिंग कर
रहा है जो पोर्ट को स्कैन कर रहा है कि
कौन सा पोर्ट ओपन है, कौन सा पोर्ट क्लोज
है या कौन सा होस्ट अप है, कौन सा होस्ट
डाउन है, वो मेरा आईपी नहीं वो गेटवे कर
रहा है। इज इट पॉसिबल?
इज इट पॉसिबल?
टेल मी एवरीवन। इज इट पॉसिबल?
प्लीज आंसर माय क्वेश्चन इज इट पॉसिबल
किसी को भी नहीं पता।
यस इट इज पॉसिबल। अगर मैं चाहता हूं कि कि
जो सामने जो नेटवर्क टीम है या शोक
एनालिस्ट टीम है क्योंकि मेरा पर्पज क्या
है? मेरा पर्पज क्या है? इवेज इव मेरे को
क्या करना है? आईडीएस से बचना है। अपने आप
को इवेट करना है। अपने को हाइड करना है।
दूसरा मुझे क्या करना है? स्पुक पैकेट
भेजना है। तो उस तरीके से
मैं क्या कर सकता हूं कि मैं रिक्वेस्ट जो
भेज सकता हूं तो जो आपकी जो नेटवर्क टीम
है उसको दिखाई देगा कि ओके जो स्कैनिंग जो
पैकेट्स आ रहे हैं वह आ रहे हैं गेटवे से।
उसका एक ही तरीका है वो है आपका डिक आईपी
के थ्रू। ओके? और कंडीशन है उसकी एक ही
कंडीशन है। उसको एक ही कंडीशन में आप
परफॉर्म कर सकते हो। आप उस नेटवर्क से
कनेक्टेड होने चाहिए। आप उस नेटवर्क से
कनेक्टेड होने चाहिए जो कि मैं उस नेटवर्क
से कनेक्टेड हो। तो मैं इसे कैसे परफॉर्म
कर सकता हूं? देखिए एन मैप
हफन पीएन देन
स्टील स्कैन देन सर्विस वर्जन देन उसके
बाद मैं हफन पोर्ट मेंशन कर देता हूं। अभी
पॉसिबल 3389
ओके देन उसके बाद हफन एफ फ्रेगमेंटेड
पैकेट उसके बाद डेटा लेंथ भी मेंशन कर
देता हूं। डाटा लेंथ आप डेटा लेंथ भी मेंट
कर मेंशन कर सकते हैं। एल इ एन जी टी एच
लेंथ इक्वल टू फॉर एग्जांपल मैंने रखी 200
एंड उसके बाद हफन डी आप मेंशन करोगे हफन
डी डी मतलब डिको आईपी तो मैं मेंशन करूंगा
192.168.0.1
दिस इज़ माय गेटवे आईपी देन उसके बाद मेरा
टारगेट आईपी 1992.168.0
22 2
और जैसे आप हिट एंटर करोगे मतलब मैं क्या
कर रहा हूं होस्ट डिस्क को स्कैन करके
स्टिल चिन सिन पैकेट भेज रहा हूं सर्विस
वर्जन डिटेक्शन कर रहा हूं इन्हीं पोर्ट
के ऊपर फ्रेगमेंटेड
अप्रोच को यूज़ करके डाटा लेंथ 200 उसके
बाद डिकोय डी मतलब डिकोय आईपी कौन सा
रहेगा मेरा गेटवे आईपी रहेगा और हिट एंटर
कर दिया देखिए हफन हफन डाटा एल इ एन जी टी
एच ओके लेंथ की स्पेलिंग गलत है मेरी ओके
एंड
क्योंकि यहां पर मैं आईपी स्पूफ कर रहा
हूं। अगर आप डीप डेको के अंदर अभी क्या है
मैं उस नेटवर्क से कनेक्टेड हूं। लेकिन,
अगर मैं चाहूं तो यहां पर और भी आईपी
एड्रेस मेंशन करना करना चा कर सकता हूं।
जिनको मैं स्पूफिंग आईपी की तरफ तरह भेजना
चाहता हूं। ओके? अभी मैं डेट इन डाटा
लेंथ। वेट वेट वेट
दिस इज आल्सो अ वे
टू फुल योर आईडीएस
देखिए
अगर आप इसको वायरस में देखोगे तो आपको जो
नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक दिखेगा वह 192.168.0.1
से ही दिखाई देगा। रेदर देन जो मेरा IP
एड्रेस है 192 168.0
160 के बजाय आपको इसी से दिखाई देगा।
किससे?1
से। गेटवे आईपी से। तो वहां पर जो नेटवर्क
ट्रैफिक एनालिस्ट बैठे होंगे जो वहां पर
आपके सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर होंगे या शॉक
टीम होगी उसको लगेगा कि जो मेरा जो गेटवे
आईपी है उनकी कंपनी का वही यह रिक्वेस्ट
भेज रहा है और उनको शक भी नहीं होगा। ठीक
है? कुछ टाइम के लिए एवरीवन गॉट क्लियर।
देयर आर टू टेक्निक्स जो मैंने आपको बताया
कि इवज आईडीएस इवजन टेक्निक्स कौन-कौन सी
है? एक तो फ्रेगमेंटेड पैकेट भेज गए।
दूसरी डिकोय आईपी भेज के कैसे आपको देखिए
एक मिनट यह रहा अदर देयर अदर ऑप्शंस आर
आल्सो अवेलेबल फॉर एग्जांपल दी ये रहा
ये रहे ये रहे देखो अभी डी मैंने भेजा था
सेंड स्कैन फ्रॉम स्पूड आईपी एड्रेस आप
ऐसे भी मेंशन कर सकते हो IPपी एड्रेस की
लिस्ट भी मेंशन कर सकते हो दूसरा या आप
क्या कर सकते हो यह यहां पे सेम है या हफन
एस यूज़ करके आप डोमेन नेम भी भेज सकते हो
आप क्या कर सकते हो डोमेन नेम भी भेज सकते
हो कि किस डोमेन से आप चाहते हो देखो यह
रहा यह रहा यह रहा यह रहा www
microsoft.com www facebook.com स्कैन
Facebook फ्रॉम microsoft किसको लगेगा कि
Microsoft Facebook को स्कैन कर रहा है।
ओके? तो स्पुप डीएनएस तो दीज़ आर द वेज़ तो
आप अपने क्या कर सकते हो? जो आईडीएस को
इवेट कर सकते हो। ठीक है? एक कुछ टाइम के
लिए और अपनी रिक्वेस्ट पास कर सकते हो
ताकि वह ब्लॉक ना करें। तो मैंने आपको
सिखाया कि पोर्ट स्कैनिंग कैसे करते हैं।
सर्विस वर्जन कैसे डिटेक्ट करते हैं।
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम कैसे डिटेक्ट करते हैं।
फायर वाल को फायर वाल की प्रेजेंस को कैसे
डिटेक्ट करना है कि होस्ट के ऊपर ऊपर कोई
फायर वाल कॉन्फ़िगरर्ड है या नहीं है या
आईडीएस जो इंट्रोड डिटेक्शन सिस्टम्स होते
हैं उनसे इवेट कैसे करना है। वो भी दो
टेक्निक्स मैंने आपको बताया। तो दिस इज़ द
चिट्स्टट्स जो जो आपके सामने अवेलेबल्स
हैं। तो एन मैप से इतने सारे काम कर सकते
हो आप। तो आई होप दिस दिस वाज़ द कांसेप्ट।
दिस वाज़ द टॉपिक। आज का टॉपिक यही था। तीन
ही टॉपिक मैं आपको बताने वाला था। नेक्स्ट
क्लास में जो मैं आपको बताऊंगा वो आपका
रहेगा एन मैप की स्क्रिप्ट। स्क्रिप्ट को
कैसे यूज़ कर सकते हो और कुछ और इंपॉर्टेंट
ऑप्शंस देन उसके बाद हमारा एन मैप खत्म हो
जाएगा और स्कैनिंग पार्ट भी हमारा खत्म हो
जाएगा। उसके बाद हम एंटर करेंगे एनमरेशन
पार्ट में। तो अभी भी किसी का कोई डाउट है
तो मुझसे पूछ सकता है। अभी मैं इसको एंड
कर देता हूं। क्लोज द टर्मिनल एंड
आप मुझसे पूछ सकते हैं। ओके। स्टिल किसी
को कोई डाउट है?
हां, मैक एड्रेस को भी सुप किया जा सकता
है।
उसकी अलग टेक्निक्स है।
प्लीज नेक्स्ट 5 मिनट आपके सामने रिलेटेड
टू कांसेप्ट। आप मुझसे डाउट पूछ सकते हैं।
देयर आर ओनली 42 स्टूडेंट्स। तो दिस इज अ
बेड फॉर मी।
लेकिन मुझे लगता है कि आज सभी स्टूडेंट्स
ने एंजॉय किया होगा एन मैप की क्लास में।
बहुत सारी चीजें आपको सीखने को मिली होंगी
और मे बी कुछ डाउट्स रहे होंगे जो पुराने
स्टूडेंट्स हैं जिनको एन मैप के बारे में
इंफॉर्मेशन भी होगी। अगर उनके कोई डाउट्स
भी रहे होंगे तो वह भी क्लियर हो गए
होंगे।
यस आर्यन
थैंक यू राकेश।
किसी को कोई डाउट है? प्लीज आस्क मी नाउ।
नंबर नहीं मिल सकता।
ओके थैंक यू दीपांशु।
किसी को कोई डाउट है?
टॉपिक से रिलेटेड किसी को भी कोई डाउट है?
आर्यन नंबर नहीं मिल सकता।
ओके तो सेशन को एंड करते हैं। फिर भी किसी
का कोई डाउट है तो कमेंट सेक्शन में मुझसे
पूछ सकता है। जब वीडियो अपलोड हो जाती है
आपकी YouTube के ऊपर। मैं डेली आपके
कमेंट्स देखता हूं और आपके डाउट रिजॉल्व
करने की कोशिश करूंगा। नेक्स्ट क्लास विल
बी मे बी डे आफ्टर टुमारो मे बी बट नॉट
श्योर ओके सर डीसी जेएसपी एथिकल हैकिंग
एंड साइबर सिक्योरिटी कोर्स एंड आई कैन
वाच दिस सेशन आल्सो ओके गुड अश्विन
काफी हेल्पफुल रहेगा आपके लिए
और उसके बाद जब यह दोनों कंप्लीट हो जाए
तो आप गो टू डीसीएसपी दिस इज द एडवांस
सर्टिफिकेशन कोर्स
फ्री सर्टिफिकेट की कोई वैल्यू नहीं होती।
ओके तो सेशन को एंड करते हैं। थैंक यू।
बाय-ब गुड डे एंड सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन।
नेक्स्ट सेशन में हम आपसे मिलेंगे। ओके?
जल्दी मिलेंगे। तो प्लीज तब तक आप अपने
रिवाइज कीजिए। प्रैक्टिस करते रहिए रहिए।
कमांड्स के बारे में जो भी मैं चिटशीट्स
या जो भी रिसोर्सेज आपको बताता हूं, प्लीज
उसको सेव कर लीजिए। अपने बुकमार्क कर
लीजिए। जो अपकमिंग क्लासेस हैं आपकी या आप
जो सीटीएफ परफॉर्म करने वाले हो या आप
अपकमिंग कोई भी सर्टिफिकेशन देने वाले हो
या इन फ्यूचर कभी भी किसी भी कंपनी में
किसी भी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन में काम करने वाले
हो तो यह जितनी भी चीटशीट है आपकी काफी
हेल्पफुल होंगी स्टार्टिंग में और जब एक
बार आप इनको यूज़ करना सीख जाओगे उसके बाद
आपको चीटशीट की जरूरत नहीं होती फिर आपको
याद रहेंगे उंगलियों पर तो ओके थैंक यू
बाय बाय गुड नाइट एंड सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट
सेशन